what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it what are we
talking about today we're going to talk
about where we live what the Bible says
about this place that we live on and I
got my good friend here Josh from
founded Earth Brothers he's got an
amazing Channel go check out founded
Earth Brothers on YouTube and check out
the amazing videos he's got say what's
up Josh what's up everybody I'm blessed
to be here and I know I'm probably not
the only one doing the air drums during
the intro music
that's jamming out yeah man I was
sitting there like trying to share this
post on my phone and it was lagging I
was just sitting there like dancing and
heart racing because the countdown going
down and all that but man I love it I'm
really excited to talk about this topic
because I remember it was about 2016
that I maybe 2015 that I first started
hearing about terms like Earth and
things like that and you know it's like
it's ridiculous like I'm not even going
to look at that I'm not going to waste
my time on that but um a friend of mine
who believed the same as me on a lot of
other things was saying dude you just
really need to look at it even if you
just want to debunk it so I was like
well that'll be easy you know so I
looked into it and I started seeing a
lot of good evidences a lot of uh things
that were tough to debunk honestly and
for like 8 months months I I think it
was just around that amount of time I
was looking at the topic and I was like
okay both models could work I could see
well you know it could be a globe and
there could be we could be um orbiting
and all this stuff or it could work the
other way where we're stationary and The
Luminaries are spinning over us it could
be that the Moon is smaller than Earth
and the Sun is a thousand times bigger
than Earth and they just happen to be
the right distance to where they Eclipse
each other perfectly you know what I'm
saying or they're both local and similar
in size and that's why they Eclipse each
other you know what I mean so you could
look at it like okay both models could
work and I was doing that for
months and then the longer I looked at
it the only model that began to crumble
was this heliocentric Globe model I
didn't expect that I didn't go into this
thinking that that was going to happen
you know and so I want to talk about
this top Toc openly candidly honestly
from scripture and from science and I
don't want I I I wish that we could look
at all kinds of topics without getting
triggered without getting offended
without saying
unsubscribed why can't we just talk
about stuff why can't we look at things
logically and rationally and biblically
and see what where the evidence weighs
out and you can agree different you can
believe different than I can and we can
still be friends and me and Jos don't
believe the same on everything and we
still have each other on our shows and
talk about topics because why are we
going to let literally the shape of
something destroy our friendship and our
relationships with each other so yeah I
seen it break up marriages like sadly
like the truth about the world believing
what the Bible says you know and
investigating it I've seen marriages
fall apart that is like the saddest
thing and it's something that you should
not really be divided over or you know
it shouldn't bother us that somebody
believes something different like um
especially Globe Believers that doesn't
bother me I'm not like oh my goodness
you believe that because I believed it
for yeah more than 30 years and finished
my Master's Degree was teaching science
thought I knew it all and was getting
wise and I had a big humbling experience
that made me investigate it and I think
you probably investigated it before I
did wow and I was I think early 2017
just starting to have some miracles
happen again for the second time in my
life wow that humbled me enough to
investigate it and I would never it's
not like I I I already thought that I
was humble but being humble enough to
look into that took me some Miracles and
I wasn't even looking into it because I
was like H maybe this is what the Bible
says I was looking into it like why is
this guy talking about something so dumb
let me just see what he's saying about
it that was how they they clickbaited me
because I was like this sounds so stupid
let me just click on that and oh my
goodness the Holy Spirit was like this
is true look at into it you know and it
was a ride from there so it's been a
journey and I saw you near the start of
this journey that's when we met at a
Meetup and I was terrified thinking what
if somebody finds out I believe in this
like you know like and of course my
friends happen to be at that place and
now they make fun of us to this day but
it's worth being made fun of to find the
truth no matter how crazy it sounds it's
worth being made fun of and that's one
of the prayers I had answered was show
me the truth about creation I don't care
how crazy it sounds and that was how I
worded
it he showed me the truth about creation
and it did sound crazy at first but the
more you look into it the more it sounds
logical and makes sense and it's
powerful life-changing and I see a lot
of life-changing brothers and sisters in
the chat I see Tracy Jones and Tyler
Porter good to see you guys and many
others if I've missed you I see a lot of
you in there some truth soldiers amen
welcome if this is your first time
seeing this topic be patient we're going
to dive deep into this I'm I'm excited I
compiled some slides to go over some
things but it's trying to compile eight
years of research into just one little
quick presentation is not easy so we are
not covering everything right but we
will try to to answer as many questions
and then we'll have a Q&A at some point
whenever you guys want to yeah beginning
or so I've been wanting to build a
presentation on this topic for years but
uh where I worked before doing YouTube
it wasn't a topic I was allowed to talk
about so who has time after work to
build presentations you know so I never
did it and um but I've been wanting to
talk about it I'm like man I just need
to invite Josh on and and I I said just
give us like biblical cosmology 101 I
want I want to see scripture and science
when I first looked into it I only did
science because I was like scripture can
be interpreted different ways and this
and that so I just looked at the
scientific evidence and like I said you
can see things too far away um there was
a lot of things that didn't make sense
about orbits and tilts and all these
things and I just started being like wow
like I I was convinced through science
and then when I looked at the scriptures
I was like oh my goodness like how could
we ever have believed the heliocentric
Globe when I'm seeing things in Genesis
so I can't wait to get into this man
let's uh let's check it out here's your
first slide yeah let's get started I I
wanted to pull up something without
going into a huge history lesson would
just show you some key figures because
when you start talking about this the
two biggest questions is why would they
lie yeah and who all are they and so the
who they are and the why they lie is a
huge topic it's an important topic to
understand it's biblical because we look
back at all the biblical deceptions and
people falling for these false deities
and doing so instantly and we never
think to go who were they who was
deceiving these people who watch the
hands of God part The Waters who was
doing these things there were were
powers of Darkness at work back then and
they never went away there is no point
in the word where it says okay this
happened and now they're going to stop
doing deceptions the word tells us the
opposite it says the resurrection has
happened all these things have happened
now there's going to be deceptions
there's going to be grand delusions
there's going to be a son of predition
there's going to be all these things and
the most high is going to let it happen
why so that the people that love the
truth will be saved and those who don't
love the truth they're not going to be
saved so you really have to love the
truth and so you can believe in the
globe and love the truth I believed in
it and loved the truth I believed in the
globe heliocentric model and I had
miracles happen I had salvation and so
the difference was once I found the
truth about biblical creation it changed
me it changed my faith it changed the
word it made it a science book and boy
oh boy is it a science book I'm finding
that out even with life science and to
change the subject real quick I'll get
back on to biblical cosmology uh
speaking of the science I'm I was a
biology teacher when I started coming
into this and I'm still teaching biology
classes now from a creation standpoint
and it's really changing the way I see
intelligent design it's powerful and we
I was looking into how many chromosomes
people have and how and like
reproduction and hybrids and all that
stuff because people ask why can't you
reproduce with different species and
different things you know and so a
student had asked me this years ago and
I looked into it and there was this
beast likee creature that had 46
chromosomes it had horns you know like
and it was like this big big bull
looking creature and I thought man
that's weird I never saw that before but
you hear about being grafted in in the
Bible and it's talking about an olive
tree that you're grafted into that's
this this the plant that they chose with
grafting in to Israel and Paul's talking
about this in the Book of Romans and as
I'm looking at how many chromosomes a
person has there's a list of organisms
and plants that have 46 chromosomes and
there's only a few there's not a lot and
there's only one plant and it was the
Olive Tree that has 46 chromosomes and
when you're grafting something into a
plant it has to be of the same kind and
have the same number of chromosomes and
I thought wow this this Bible when this
was written we didn't know about
chromosomes we didn't know you know
about any of those things but our father
knew and His prophets were speaking
through the Holy Spirit and so they're
telling us things that are powerful in
the spirit and just like that genetics
example with the Olive Tree having 46
chromosomes there's power to the word
and there's there's a reason why it's so
accurate they could have picked any
plant and not one of them would have had
the 46 chromosomes like us and so that's
a big prezygotic barrier so I didn't
want to bring that up so you were a
science teacher so you're not some
ignorant like flat earther whatever you
your whole life your whole career was
science still is but you did it as a
career for the public school system now
you teach so how tell people where they
can find out how they can if if they're
homeschooled or whatever how they can
get their kids enrolled in your your
science uh schools yeah if if you guys
even if you're not into biblical
cosmology yet just be careful somebody
said in the comments yeah I tell people
not to look into it unless you're ready
to become one and so be careful be very
careful because if you start looking
into it you're gonna things are going to
make sense and um but yeah I I teach
life science and earth science classes
and we do so it's become a worldwide
school we have so many students from all
over that are the best students I've
ever had they're the hardest working
students they're putting out the best
work I've ever seen reading some of the
work today and the things that they've
done I mean I'm just like fired up
seeing the things that they are finding
and teaching me and so creation standard
was actually something I would not have
came up with on my own but as a science
teacher I had freedom in my own
classroom to be not deceitful but to be
very sneaky and teach children the truth
without getting in trouble and doing it
in a way that's not just blatant you
know you had to be cunning and so I
would do these things and I could teach
my own kids certain things and helped
them see how false Evolution was however
I got placed in the classroom with other
teachers and it made me see how much
we're in a war zone and these children
are being deceived told that they don't
matter they came from nothing and that
nothing became an aeba somehow and that
amoeba became dinosaurs 100,000 pound
creatures that all of a sudden went
extinct and then devolved into birds and
now you're just a mutated bird with no
feathers you know like you just there's
just so many weird lies they have to
create to keep us all in this trap of
not mattering and not and not caring
about anything because life doesn't
matter it's random and so once I saw the
damage being done I was like got to
create something and I was going to just
do it on the side but I I knew that I
couldn't do it justice unless I stepped
out full-time and so this year I've been
teaching for 16 years in the public
school setting and I've been blessed to
now my 17th year first time teaching and
I'm teach outside of the public school
and I've worked harder than I've ever
worked in my life I have four different
preps two life science two earth science
children of all ages ages three to 80
like we have it like that's the kind of
program I wanted so people can come in
and learn even if you feel like you got
your college degree and I've had people
like hey I went through college and I
didn't learn anything about intelligent
design I want to learn and so we're
investigating things and finding new
proof it's it's changing my life it's
powerful so creation standard.com that
simple you can go there you can join us
late or you can wait until next year I'm
going to try to do this again next year
if it works out financially I'm really
hoping to I don't want to give my verbal
commitment yet but that's where my
heart's at is staying with it doing this
again adding some more actual book
resources and all that next year so we
don't just create it as we go this year
we're creating it as we go and it is a
journey registration right there on the
homepage my wife is my secretary if you
don't get a response real soon I have to
fire her I'm just kidding she's pretty
she's usually pretty prompt she's she's
had to take on a lot of of
responsibilities with this so that I
could just do instructions and she does
everything else like that's literally
what I focus on is instruction so it's
been a blessing having a good a good
secretary an attractive
secretary you brought up a verse I
wanted to read it while we're looking at
this um so it says and with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness in
them that perish because they receive
not a love of the truth the truth that
they might be saved and in the context
here it says uh and for this cause God
shall send them strong delusion that
they should believe a lie that they all
might be damned who believe not the
truth but had pleasure and
unrighteousness so you know we some
people say look man we don't need to
look at that but I I don't believe that
truth is ever
sent to harm the truth will set you free
in all departments and so you mentioned
something about not being deceptive but
having to be smart and I thought of this
verse where it says behold I sent you
forth as sheep in the midst of wolves
that was you and the public school
system and it says be therefore wise as
serpents and harmless as doves so I
believe that's what you were doing yeah
I had to and it was quite the journey I
got in trouble three times but it was
worth getting in trouble not
for yeah I got called at the principal's
office three times more than my whole
school history when I was a student I
think yeah almost and so yeah I got
called to the office three times not for
my classroom experiences but for my
online presence talking about this stuff
like I am now so I had to go into hiding
and eventually I just decided to come
out of hiding and so now pretty much
everyone in my science department knew I
was a Biblical Earth creationist and so
might as well become a fool the word
tells us 1 Corinthians 318-19 become a
fool we're going to go over that I want
to go ahead and get started though
because there's a lot to cover I do not
want to um leave any questions
unanswered so if you have questions
think about them and we will answer them
as we go but real quick this picture
right here this is a brief history of
the heliocentric model coming about some
of the key figures and it goes way
deeper than secret societies mankind
could not come up with these lies on
their own they needed powers of Darkness
that have been around since before the
flood to teach the wisdom of the father
to mankind the same powers of dark
darkness that knew who the Messiah was
when he was casting them out into the
swine and into the water of course they
were probably afraid of water because of
the flood but the the powers that
shouldn't be this stuff isn't a very
very old light it started coming really
big into fruition in about the
1540s where Pope Paul theii approves
this Jesuit order and that Jesuit order
once it's approved cernus comes along
three years later I'm thinking he might
be associated with that Society but he
dedicates a heliocentric Treatise to
Pope Paul III the same one that approved
that and then the 1590s of course you
have secret Oaths secret societies
replicating the same Oaths as like the
Jesuits did you'll notice with secret
societies they have Oaths that bind them
just like the Fallen did on Mount Herman
they bound themselves to corrupt the
world and these people have secrets and
they're not keeping secrets because
they're planning a surprise party and
they have our best interest at heart
it'd be good to think that but usually
when somebody has kept secrets for many
hundreds of years it's not to make a
huge huge huge really good surprise for
you it'd be nice to dream about that but
they do dark things at the very tippy
top and there's Masons out there that
are good people there's NASA scientists
that are out there that are good people
the lower levels they're not they don't
know I think that's why Hitler I was
reading when we were at the in DC like
you were we got stuck there and we were
passing through and I was reading about
Hitler in one of the um I'm afraid to
talk about too many things but the uh
lower level peoples of the secret
society he let them kind of come back in
get re-educated but the people at the
top they were put to death I think he
knew that they knew too much I really
don't know what the whole deal was with
that I'm not saying he's a good guy or
anything but I'm saying he knew the
power structure and so he was letting
the little bottom people free
essentially and so lots of little powers
of Darkness outwork forming some of
these things it's going to get dark I
will warn you I'm not going to go into
all the history um who they are and why
they lie we've got documentaries on that
on our channel that are literally called
just that who they are and why they lie
so you can look that up but there's some
order of events that had to take place
to hide the reality of the biblical
Earth model things like guarding
Antarctica are essential and space
travel are essential and those are two
aspects you're going to see world powers
agreeing on peacefully and that's what
you have to look out for when world
powers are agreeing on something
peacefully it brings us back to the
Tower of Babel where they all had the
same language they were all peacefully
trying to accomplish a task of going up
to the firmament and the most high says
that they are united they have one
language I'm some I'm paraphrasing here
this is exact words but they're United
they have one language and nothing
they're set out to do will be impossible
for them that's right and so how is that
not impossible going the firmament you
know because they're United they are all
one language and so he changed their
languages he sent them all around the
world and that's where you get these new
nations with languages and everything
before that everybody could speak the
same language there's no need if you're
born speaking a language to change it
that was something that was changed by
the most high for a reason and now they
are uniting the Nations the United
Nations the international space stations
all these things involve uniting and
you'll notice they do so peacefully and
so the who they are aspect it's easy to
see just looking at sculptures and
history they worship Su gods and they
worship the lightbearer Satan just look
at Satan over here 1795 a precursor to
the modern day Lady Liberty Liberty from
the law being Lawless that's why there's
a broken chain on her ankle not that
it's a really a she I mean look at these
people they have the same physique same
bicep right here probably went to the
same gym so Lady Liberty Helios like all
these deities they're all interrelated
and it goes way back before Christ you
hear about sun god Worship in the Bible
as being an Abomination so it has been
going on not going to get deep into that
just wanted to show you some imagery and
let you know that those Powers have
continued to pass on the torch Rome
essentially never really died out and
those powers are there you can see their
marks you can see just looking down over
the White House I know Mikey you guys
talk about these things all the time and
so your people know these things I just
want to share this verse right here this
is from the book of jubilees which is a
lot like genesis same account and it's
showing you our father's Mercy because
he was talking to Moses and telling
Moses what the people were going to do
because he knows the future but his
mercy and his grace endures forever and
so he tells them he's telling Moses they
will make to themselves high places and
Groves and they have the groves today
and graven images and they will worship
each his own Graven image so as to go
astray and they will sacrifice their
children to demons and to all the works
of error of their hearts and I will send
Witnesses unto them so instead of just
wiping them out he's going to send them
Witnesses he should have just wiped them
out you see people sacrificing children
to Demons you should just wipe them out
but he's extending his Mercy sending
Witnesses but here's what happens it
says that I may witness against them but
they will not hear and will slay the
witnesses also and they will persecute
those who seek the law and they will
abgate and change everything as to work
evil before my eyes and he's telling
Moses this before he gives these people
free food from the Mana all these things
before he does all these things
nourishes them teaches them his ways
he's telling Moses this is what they're
going to do and so his Mercy is out
there he is reaching out sending
Witnesses const L they killed his son
all these things have happened and it's
still going on to this day they are
still doing those same foolish things
and so the who they are aspect I want to
cover this real quick this is the
biblical aspect and it has to do with
what a lot of people he this word the
Antichrist they think of a key figure
they think of this person but they were
dealing with this TP type of people back
then the antichrists that's why yeah
it's a spiritual thing and there can be
a certain figure who is more Antichrist
you know and more against those people
but this Spirit was at work back then
they said even now are there many
antichrists and then it tells us about
like you said here in John chapter 4 or
1 John 4:3 and every spirit that
confesses not that Jesus Christ has come
in the flesh is not of God and this is
that Spirit of antichrist that's why
people get so mad that's why the Prest
were ripping their clothes when they
found out who he was saying he was
saying that he was basically the one
that Daniel chapter 7 mentioned
returning at the right hand of the most
high with the Clouds Of Heaven you know
you have yet to see this and they're
like wait a minute he's saying he's the
Messiah coming with the Clouds Of Heaven
what's going on let's rip our clothes
we're angry they were mad even though
they saw the Miracles they never denied
that he did Miracles they saw them still
put them to death because of those
spiritual Powers talking in their ears
and working and so the essential
ingredient here though 1 John 2:22 a
bunch of twos there easy to remember
that one it says who is a liar but he
that denieth that Jesus is the anointed
one or the Christ he is anti- Anointed
one or Antichrist that denieth the
father and the son and so that's a big
deal and when you look at what they're
doing if you can't really deny the son
because everyone's teaching that message
now you got to deny the father what was
their desperation
create a big bang eliminate the father
and then the son has to become a fairy
tale they couldn't hide him couldn't
sweep him under the rug people were
still talking about him but they tried
their best to eliminate the father in
Genesis 1 with a big bang explosion and
remember you saw the graphics earlier on
Pope Paul III approving the Jesuit order
it was a Jesuit priest who invented the
Big Bang this is not a conspiracy theory
you can literally just Google it just
type in who created The Big Bang Theory
it's public knowledge um you were just
talking about the spirit of antichrist
working through you know the rulers of
the world and stuff like that we talk
about that a lot we've been talking
about it with Trump and Elon and um it's
weird a lot of people can't believe the
concept that Satan is literally the God
of this world working through the
governments of this world and people
still put trust in man in governments
and uh so there's a a verse I wanted to
show here in Ezekiel it's it's a the
context is about the destruction of
Lucifer some people disagree that
Lucifer is Satan or whatever but thou
has defiled the sanctuaries by the
multitude of thine
iniquity I will destroy thee Oh covering
cherub but it's addressing a a prince
this Prince
Tyrus and it says Thou Hast been in Eden
the Garden of God Ty was wasn't back
Tyrus wasn't back in the Garden of Eden
every precious stone was your covering
you were in the Holy Mountain of God
you've walked up and down it you were
perfect in your ways until or from that
day that you were created until iniquity
was found in thee this is the Fallen
Angel who is now Satan but the way it's
addressed is it's being addressed to the
prince of Tyrus so I wanted to just use
a Bible reference to show that Satan
does work through the kings of the world
yeah constantly working through anyone
he can they're desperate to get as many
to perish as they can and it's biblical
it's like that Spirit of the Antichrist
denying the father and the son and so if
you can eliminate that father it reminds
me of that movie that everyone's
familiar with Back to the Future where
when the parents didn't come together
there was no father essentially the Sun
goes away and you can see them starting
to vanish and that's how they've done
with eliminating the Father the Messiah
his beloved Son starts to disappear and
so it's a powerful lie and to erase that
lie you have to become foolish and that
sounds crazy it sounds mean but that's
what we're asking people to do and I
always thought that I was so wise and
never knew what this meant but it tells
us here let no man deceive himself if
any man among you seeth to be wise in
this world let him become a fool that he
may be wise sounds counterproductive but
then it goes on to clarify that the
wisdom of this world is foolishness with
Yahweh for it is written he taketh the
wise in their own craftiness amen so the
wise are crafty they're being really
crafty right now with the things they're
doing and you have to lose that worldly
wisdom and when you lose it people are
going to think you're foolish that is a
warning they will think you're foolish
but you're going to have great peace and
you're going to have truth when you do
that and we're going to put the worldly
wisdom to the test that's what we've had
to do and it's been fun it's been an eye
opening and you start seeing things once
you actually start really loving truth
and seeking it you're going to see that
the moving world that they put us on is
not just moving really really fast many
many times faster than a bullet it has
this number that we've read before the
triple six all throughout it the speed
66,6 miles per hour that's what I was
taught now you look it up and they've
rounded to 67,000 on almost every
website but that was the literal speed
why did the did the speed change or did
they calculate it different or why yeah
you have to type in exact when you start
typing in exact then you start finding
it but when you just type in how fast is
the world moving you'll get 67,000 or
approximately this and so they have to
change it to hide it now that
everybody's on to it but even the
curvature they've embedded that number
666 feet per mile squared that's how
much curvature 8 in is 666 feet per M
squared
and then the Tilt even with that beloved
tilt of 23.4 degrees the one they say is
responsible for our season changes and
all that the remainder to get to 90 66.6
degrees of course you have the Arctic
and Antarctic circles at 66.6 degrees
like that number is intertwined in many
many places yeah and that's the wisdom
of this world but if you go to our
father's wisdom what he's actually
saying about his creation he says that
the world is immovable it has a
foundation and there's a firmament above
it and on day four of creation this was
after he spent the entire day two of
creation making a structure and we'll
look at that structure we'll see proof
of it visual proof of it documentation
of it here in just a little bit but he
placed all the lights above us into that
firmament and so we have this really
nice beautiful clock with lights in it
for signs and appointed times that are
so accurate we could predict them
hundreds of years if not thousands of
years into the future and into the past
because it's that accurate of a clock
imagine having a watch like that that
kept working for thousands of years and
people could go oh I knew what time it
said on this day you know this many
years ago this is the most accurate time
piece ever created it's the most
beautiful time piece ever created and it
keeps going and it's been going and
going since he put those two lights in
the firmament of the heaven and so
they're actually in the firmament you
can't go to them you can't land on them
and so that's where we understand it's
not moving there's a firmament but Earth
it's not really flat and were going to
be really mad when you say that because
they're like wait I thought you were a
flat earther no the Earth is just dry
land and so the Gathering Together of
the Seas and are the waters he called
Seas but Earth it's essentially not flat
it's many different elevations it's just
dry land you could take Earth and hold
it in your hands you could pick up some
dry land hold it in your hand you're
holding Earth in your hand that is the
biblical definition of Earth and so when
you look at a map of the world the
continents the dry land that's Earth and
so if they were to say the four corners
of the earth and you're going wait a
minute is it Square I thought he above
the circle how is it squared and circled
and you get really confused just calm
down there's corners on the continents
this continent where they were at
there's corners on it there's corners of
dry land there's quarters of dry land as
well you can break it up in quarters
sometimes that word Corners is often the
word quarters like you're breaking it up
and so the quarters of the earth when he
says the four quarters of the earth you
can break it up like a pie chart in four
different quarters like there's so many
different ways but knowing that dry land
is Earth will make this make a lot more
sense and so setting above the circle of
the dry land makes a lot more sense when
you look at a map of reality where
there's a circle of dry land that he's
above looking down and so spreading
those Heavens out like a tent it tells
us this and Isaiah is it is he that sth
upon the circle of the dry land the
Earth not the world but the earth and
the inhabitants thereof is Grasshoppers
and I I remember a lot of people
including myself would say see he knew
about the the globe before science did
and that's what I thought but then you
read this next part that stretcheth out
the heavens as a curtain and so
spreading them out as a tent and if
you've ever put up a tent tents do not
look like Globes if you try using a tent
that looks like a globe it's not going
to work yeah so we have a barrier above
us like a tent like a tabernacle spread
out and it's not moving the world is
immovable we see that a lot of times but
I want to take a lot of you back to
where I got brainwashed and how easy it
was
because I was told that our ancestors
were ignorant they were dumb we are wise
we've got it figured out and our dumb
ancestors thought you would fall off the
edge of the Earth and even Brian Cox
this guy here says yeah no nobody ever
believed in the firmament wow but they
did every ancient cosmology believed in
it and I'll show you pictures of that in
just a second and I was then told that
Christopher Columbus was this globe
Warrior who set out to debunk these
people who thought you fall off the edge
went on these travels in 1492
well before the Beloved gravity was
invented in guess when 1666 66 oh my God
he can you go back to that Isaiah
scripture again yeah like you said a lot
of people use this to say look the Bible
they they knew that the Earth was a
globe and they use it to try and fight
you know atheists and things like that
and this was written by Isaiah and it
uses the word
Circle and when you look the same author
Isaiah and because some people say well
they didn't have the word sphere back
then or whatever but it says he will
surely violently toss turn and toss thee
like a ball so Isaiah the same person
that use the word ball this is the only
word ball in the whole Bible it just
happened to be used by the same author
Isaiah why didn't he say Earth is a ball
why do you use the word Circle so for
anyone that's watching and saying ah you
guys are just you know stretching it or
whatever no I Isaiah if he knew the
Earth was a globe he would have used the
word ball because he clearly knew that
word yeah and there was lots of
comparisons you know it's like an apple
it's like a you know he could have used
all these other images they had round
objects outside of even if the
basketball hadn't been invented like
they had spherical objects around them
you know hell Stones falling down from
the sky they had lots of spherical
objects to look at and they said he was
setting above the circle of dry land and
that Circle didn't have an edge you can
fall off of it had a firmament of above
it and so I had a deep dive into this
and we'll go into this in just a little
bit about this Christopher Columbus guy
and what they really believed in because
I was lied to I was told they believed
in that edge and they were scared of
falling off of it and he went out there
knowing he wouldn't because he believed
in the globe and wasn't worried about
falling off the bottom of a round object
how is that any different still like a
flat disc only it's a ball now and
you're upside down completely at least a
disc most of it safe until you get to
the edge this everything is is an edge
and so 1666 good old gravity being
invented by Sir Isaac Newton and then I
was told that circumnavigation fully
destroyed the globe and Christopher
Columbus didn't even circumnavigate it
wasn't until later that that happened by
a man who historians didn't write about
until 300 years after he
circumnavigated a man named Juan
Sebastian elcano I did not know that
until I started doing this class and I'm
like wait a minute okay Not only was I
lied to historians just faed to write
about a guy in their own town who did
this feat and was you know historic and
they waited 300 years imagine if we did
that with the Messiah if they were like
well they didn't write about them until
300 years later but they accept this
stuff as fact even though historians are
waiting that long and circum navigation
doesn't even debunk the globe but it was
hard to do it took them three years to
do back then and so it's not a globe
proof you can point your compass North
and go in a circle and go in a straight
line seemingly if you're pointing your
compass North the whole time you will
end up right where you started no matter
where you are on this map right the
center the center of that map is
magnetic north and if you took a compass
and put it anywhere on that map the the
needle would be pulling towards that
Center that Magnetic North Center so
essentially East is clockwise and West
is counterclockwise right yeah and you
have you have a compass that only works
when you hold it flat it works on a flat
surface when you try doing it on a globe
with a magnet on the top it doesn't work
and they say well it's like a bar magnet
shoved through the middle of the world
and then you look at what the middle of
the world looks like and it's magma and
magnets don't work when you heat them up
they lose their magnetic abilities when
they're hot and we live on what they say
is a ball of magma can't feel the heat
coming through the surface but it's a
ball of magma covered with water and so
the lie that I was told about the edge
really gets laughable when you start
digging into history and now of course
Wikipedia even says oh no they didn't
believe in the Flat Earth they all
believed in the globe and I'm like wait
a minute whoa whoa whoa I was taught
this like it was fact and the reason
they're saying that now is because you
look back into Real historic documents
where they're writing about it this guy
here in the 1800s had Works translated
from into English and looked into what
they were believing back then and they
believed in the firmament he says this
right here St Paul also in his Epistles
to the Hebrews compares the Heavens to a
tabernacle or tent spread over the Earth
hence the causest maintained these
people back then that the Earth must be
flat like the bottom of the tent they
did not mention the edge and falling off
of it however this is where it gets
funny the globular people the globular
form of the Earth in the in the
possibility of an opposite and
inhabitable hemisphere but maintained
that it would be impossible to arrive
there in the in consequence of the heat
of the Tor zone so they had their
imaginations the globe believers you had
both the biblical Earth believing in the
firmament aspect and you had the glow
Believers so you had both beliefs going
on back then and it says As for the
steering to the West in search of India
they observed that the circumference of
the earth must be so great as to require
at least three years to the voyage and
those who should undertake it must
perish of hunger and thirst from the
impossibility of carrying Provisions for
so long a period And so Wikipedia also
tells you that oh no they had the globe
math figured out they inherited it from
the Greeks and they all understood
everything meanwhile they thought it was
so far away you just couldn't get there
with without traveling for three years
and then here's not the least absurd of
their objections that should a ship even
succeed in reaching the extremity of
India she could never get back again why
not because of the edge for the
rotundity of the globe would present a
kind of a mountain so a mountain of
curved water of which it would be
impossible for her to sell with the most
favorable wind so they weren't afraid of
the edge they were afraid of
curvature I was never taught that I was
told they were dumb they were barbaric
they believed in an edge and Christopher
Columbus proved him wrong when he went
on this journey and his journey didn't
even circumnavigate he that concept is
an evolution that's a Darwin and
evolution mindset that we think people
in the past were dumb they were ignorant
they worshiped ID you know we like oh
they worshiped Stone blah blah blah we
worship Taylor Swift they were no dumber
than us now they were way smarter Adam
and Eve were perfect
you think about their offspring um Cain
and Abel and then Noah you think those
people were dumb no man the Bible says
that we're going to be as in the days of
Noah in the last days so that makes me
question I wonder if there was like
maybe there was some crazy technology
back then who knows but I know were SM
still marveling at their inventions the
inventions of the Egyptians the
Babylonians how are they doing this how
did they do it how did they have help
making these structures we don't
understand well because a lot of these
structures were pre flood structures the
flood was a great reset they had the
wisdom of the Fallen they carved it into
stone that's how it was able to survive
the flood and be passed on to current
Generations they learned these things
that were carved in stone and so that's
why probably one of the reasons why they
call Masons Masons you know it has to do
with the stonework that they found After
the flood the sons of Noah and their
children they found these things and
they it says in the book of jubilees
they sinned on account of it and so that
wisdom of the father
returned they learned a lot of powers of
Darkness they were being plagued by
demons and it it tells us that they were
really being plagued by demons After the
flood but the father bound a large
percentage so what we're dealing with
now is nowhere near what it was um sorry
I'm laughing dude I'm I'm looking at
your pair shape NASA you gotta explain
it because in you know we've been
looking at this topic for a long time
and there's a lot of memes in the
biblical cosmology thing but when Neil
degros Tyson was question about the
shape of the earth he goes it's actually
pearshaped is you know when when you're
like spinning pizza dough and it gets a
little it gets flat and wide it's funny
mention flat because it kind of flattens
out it gets a little chubby is that's a
good word for it it gets a little chubby
in the MD around the middle so you know
Earth is actually it's not round it's
not a ball it's it's actually pearshaped
he insulted the world called it chubby
and then said it was pear shaped I'm
sure the world didn't like that very
much and the mountain of shape curved
isid yeah oblate it's oblate it's sort
ofid yeah so it's an oblate spheroid he
says and that just means that there's a
mountain of curved water higher than
Mount Everest at the equator and so when
you're going around the equator you're
far enough above sea level you're higher
than Mount Everest I don't know why that
water is not frozen but that's how high
you would be I mean it is a large
mountain of curvature and this is just a
snapshot of all the past civilizations
what they believed in and you see a
firmament you don't ever usually see a
disc that fall off of there's usually
some sort of covering and that's because
all that information originated with the
Genesis truth with that biblical proof
or truth of creation they all knew it
they all understood it you can tell the
world's not moving if somebody told you
it was you'd be thinking how it must be
moving really really slow at a snail
Pace because I don't feel it it must be
moving in a straight line because if
you're ever going around a curve you
notice there's a curve you're going
around in a car or on a roller coaster
but the world is moving in a curved path
spinning curved around path around the
Sun flying through the Galaxy like we're
going to get into those speeds but the
circum navigation aspect I wanted to
share this what's that do you happen to
know when the first illustration of a
globe came about because you're looking
at these old etchings or these old
drawings they're all a flat with a
firmament on top when did we first see a
globe drawing it happened it was a sun
god worship concept that came about and
people like aanes you you'll hear them
mentioned quite often he was living in a
town that had a sanctuary of Apollo
remember the Apollo missions Apollo is a
son God they named their mission a sun
god mission where they were going
allegedly through the firmament to get
to the moon because they knew it was
there they know they can't go to the
moon and so the sun god missions this
guy lived in a sun god town they had a
Temple of Zeus and ostanes was a Zeus
worshipper he had dedicated a scepter to
Zeus and he was using is Sun God phallic
symbol objects of worship to measure the
so-called curvature and these are sun
god deities he was doing this for he
wasn't doing this for Science and the
math even Neil degrass Tyson who we were
just talking about says you can do the
same thing with a local light source and
a flat surface right that you can with
the curved surface in the Obelisk you
can do it both it works both ways
perfectly and so now when you look it up
they'll say oh he used sticks and
shadows they don't want you knowing he
he was a son God worshipper it wasn't
sticks and shadows Neil degrass Tyson
says it was Welles and shadows and I'm
like why are there so many stories and
you look into it because he was in the
mega Center of sun god worship this guy
and he was devout it is a religion he
was a religious guy but he worshiped
Zeus and so ostanes when people quote
him like he's some scientist
mathematician he was not he was a
religious guy he knew math but the
writings about him and his experiment
guess what they're nowhere to be found
wow we're dealing with this is what
somebody said about him there's no
original documentation it's not like the
Bible where there's manuscript after
manuscript and so this guy pretty much
coming on the scene more so in recent
times and they just act like oh back
then everybody knew about his math how
this was before the internet right you
know what I mean like how did everybody
just know his math they were like oh
guys aras's figured it out this sun god
worshipper over here let's all adopt his
math and yeah now we got it figured out
no meanwhile they were too dumb they
they in the 1400s yeah right you know
it's like stories aren't adding up and
then when we finally did start
circumnavigating and collecting data it
didn't match the globe Antarctica as a
continent should be 11,000 miles in
circumference but when they were going
around Captain Cook in in the
1770s that's close to when we were
having some big things happening with
America right he went 62,000 nautical
miles and this is his log he said no
continent was to be found basically all
you could see his ice and he was trying
to go around it took him three years and
then the HMS British Challenger 78,000
miles going around in the 1870s getting
closer to recent times matching the
circumference of the biblical Earth
model and so if Antarctica was as big as
their travels that's how big it would
look compared to the globe I wanted you
to see a visual but the reason it looks
that way is because you can unwrap that
and wrap it around the real world makes
more sense no way dude this is my first
time never seeing that that illustration
right there I'm learning this stuff
brand new because I'm having to go back
and look at the stuff that I was
indoctrinated to believe and I'm just
finding out that there's logs this was a
scientific Journey the HMS British
Challenger it was scientific they were
trying to find new species and exploring
and of course they were going and
docking in certain places they weren't
staying right near the ice wall but if
they're going 78,000 miles around an
11,000 mile continent they are horrible
explorers and these people were funded
by the British like they were doing this
stuff for science
they refund yeah and so their their data
is out there I looked it up and I was
surp I was not surprised when I found
out that people were writing about it
and saying look guys this biblical this
globe Earth stuff is a lie look at their
data and I go back and I look at their
data and it's still published in like
museums they still have those logs and
they still use them and they charted a
lot of new species and things in the
ocean and so there's a lot of things we
don't know that they're just kind of
tucking away but you can listen to
Cernic's himself and I'm going to read
his quote after I read first Timothy and
you'll see he's familiar with the Bible
he actually went to college specializing
in biblical Canon probably trying to
have certain books removed is what his
goal might have been don't want to say
that's true but imagine that and so um
in this book it tells us in 1 Timothy
I'm going to skip to the last
highlighted part it says avoid profane
and Vain babblings and oppositions of
science falely socalled yeah and so
telling people to avoid the false
science here's what Mr capern us Mr
Helios worshipper he says there may be
babblers using that word babbling
remember avoid the babblings wholly
ignorant of my or of mathematics who
dare to condemn my hypothesis upon the
authority of some part of the Bible
Twisted to suit their purpose I value
them not and Scorn their unfounded
judgment so essentially people quoting
the Bible as proof of the biblical Earth
I don't value their opinion I scorn
their unfounded judgment you can hear
his anti-bible tone he does not like
people quoting the Bible to go against
his math and does his math put him above
the most high absolutely not he didn't
know where the sun was and all that
stuff back then he was just saying it's
a sun centered model yeah and look where
we're at today back then he was a
heathen that was angry at Christians
using the Bible but now today if someone
like us uses the Bible even the
Christians get mad yeah wow yeah quot
the Bible you're just misunderstanding
that wasn't literal but when I talked
about the powers of Darkness there was
more they always called themselves We
Are Legion listen to his language
finally we he's not speaking alone we
shall place the son
himself himself at the center of the
universe what finally we shall Mr cernus
so the son is a he is a deity it's a he
it's a he and he named it after his son
God Helio Helio is short for the sun god
Helios and Centric means centered around
it's not centered around the sun it's
centered around a son God the ancient
son God that was there for them to
worship they had graven images of this
statue you've seen pictures of them at
the start of this presentation and I
showed them to you so you can see how
they went through time not just after
Christ but before and Beyond to this day
even that beloved word solar system we
were making solar systems when I was in
school I didn't know that Soul was their
son God of Rome Soul en victus wow dude
Soul en victus was their son God and a
what does that mean it's a suffix that
means belonging to so you've got
centered around a son God and belonging
to a son God a system of belonging to
Soul yeah it's dark and so it is a
religion when people say Don't force
your religion on me with this stuff they
already forced it on us we were already
told hey here's a sun god model you're
forced into believing it it's going to
be in your standards you have to teach
it and it only took a couple generations
to hide the firmament because all they
had to do is say oh they believed in an
edge and people like me young innocent
going oh they believed in an edge oh
then we found out it was round oh Circle
navigation wow not once did I have a
mental image in my head of a barrier up
above us no one ever told me that in
church no one ever said it in school if
I had heard that as an option my mind
might have said let me look into that
but it was like oh disc in Space versus
globe in space you know that was your
two options and I didn't know were Sun
god- centered models and I didn't know
that Mr cernus was a sun god worshipper
so was ostanes and so was the person who
invented the Big Bang he is a Jesuit and
so there's a quick Glimpse again to
remind you going all the way back to 400
BC there's a Helios carving look at the
crown look at the crown 100 BC Roman son
God Soul Invictus look at the crown
Helios look at the crown look at the
1400 ad up there with Mr relativity
looks like they're relatives right there
looks just like him and then the old
Colossus it was a statue they call the
Statue of Liberty The New Colossus
that's actually engraved in there The
New Colossus the original Colossus was
the Statue of RADS and it was a statue
of Helios and it was the 33 meters um in
height just like the Lady Liberty from
feet to Crown and so you have that sun
god stuff going on and as you get to the
1700s then you start seeing the Satan
statue come in or painting not statue
Satan painting this is called Satan
summoning his Legions and then the
Statue of Liberty looks just like that
yeah copy paste and then 1889 of course
they just made it more blatant There's
an actual male version and they call him
Helios and so this stuff is it never
died out and then when we started having
space travel what was their first
mission did they name it after the
Messiah did they name it after the
disciples they named it after Mercury
wow
to guide The Souls of the underworld and
look at the symbol at the bottom left
yeah do you guys see the upside down
cross there or am I
hallucinating and then their next one
wow yeah it's dark they named the next
one after Atlas there's
1962 Atlas and guess who Atlas is he's
the God holding up the firmament right
that was his punishment and when you
look at Enoch the bound the angels that
were bound they were bound deep under
the Earth and like oh look he was just
bound he was just holding up the fir at
that guy one of their deities
and then of course Apollo the son god
with their Apollo missions where they
finally got their first images of the
world to fully indoctrinate us on their
son God missions and now the new modern
day ones guess who they're named after
the sister of Apollo Artemis the twin
sister the moon goddess and now she's
going to take us to the Moon Not Our
Father not hey let's pray for safety so
these people don't die in a vacuum
chamber no let's just name them after
sun gods and wow dude use these dark
Origins and these lies like lies of
evolution depend on the lies of the sun
god model and that's why you can see
their books they had the same authors I
mean I feel like they just wrote These
in modern day like ostanes over here the
Zeus worshipper on the measurements of
the earth then you have the sun god
worshipper of kernus coming in
1533 on the Revolutions of the Heavenly
Spears and then Darwin on the origins of
the species
like they couldn't differentiate their
titles they wanted them to sound the
same and look the same because they come
from the same dark Powers separated by
Generations but not not separated by the
powers of Darkness they have those
unification things going on and these
people are often given titles cernus
father of the heliocentric model Darwin
father of evolution George ler or litra
however you say his name father of the
Big Bang we got our founding fathers and
then we have our Messiah who says call
no man on Earth your father wow dude
because you have one father and he is in
Heaven nor are you to let yourselves be
called leaders because you have one
leader and he is the Messiah the
greatest among you must be servant for
whoever promotes himself will be humbled
and whoever humbles himself will be
promoted and he lived out that example
of being humble he was a servant and he
washed the feet of his servants I mean
like all these things he did showing us
how to be humble how to live and telling
us to call no man father and that's what
we do we call people father and when
you're reading a science book every
chapter oh here's the father of genetics
here's the father of this here's the
father that has these laws of physics
here's the father that has this
everybody's father you go to church Rome
wants you to call the person in their
father Oh Holy Father Pope Holy Father
you know like they're we're we're giving
these prestigious titles to men and
they're not living up to the examples of
the Messiah and they're wanting to be
called father they're wanting these big
titles and so it's dark there is a bias
and I told you I got called into the
principal's office and I was told as
long as you don't have bias you're okay
don't have any bias well I go to the
words of the people who brought up the
ideas that the world is old older than
the creation narrative and it's a man
named Charles Lyall he's the one that is
the founding father of geology and what
was his goal his goal was to free the
science from Moses that was his goal oh
my good why is that a big deal because
Moes has the creation account written
down right he wrote Genesis yeah freeing
the science from the understanding of
Genesis in the Exodus who we are where
we come from how old the world is and so
his idea of this world being millions of
years old where did it come from his
thought or assumption Earth appeared
aged that is the science looks old looks
old yep how dusty it is got wrinkles
it's old so he he said it appeared aged
and that was it that's where that idea
of millions of years started to come
from and they had to invent the
geological column and all these things
but we're gonna put George or Charles
Lyall to the test father of modern
geology and so him trying to get rid of
Moses well guess what Moses he didn't
just do all these things by himself he
had the most high with him and the most
high this is where I'm going to
hopefully open a lot of your eyes to how
real this Bible is that they're trying
to hide from us there was a pillar of
fire I've highlighted it in blue here
and it says here that Yahweh looked unto
the host of the Egyptians through the
pillar of fire and of the cloud so there
was that Pillar of Fire and the cloud
aspect but he's troubling the host of
the Egyptians and I remember seeing that
Ten Commandments movie as a child and
that was the first time I saw those
types of special effects with a a fire
touching down and it just was something
that stood out in my mind as just being
impressive like wow that is so cool cu
was real big into superheroes back then
it was pretty much idol worship I'm not
going to lie I was a huge Superman fan
and when I saw that wow my Creator can
do this he's like a superhero you know
instead of they're borrowing things from
his powers and trying to make man be
like Gods I kind of was like wow he's
got these powers and so I related to the
most high that way uh back then like
that however I didn't realize that
Pillar of Fire Not only was it mentioned
in this book not only did it help them
get across by keeping the Egyptians back
while the waters were parted this Pillar
of Fire that we read about there's proof
of this Pillar of Fire there's proof of
those chariot wheels they're still on
the bottom they're Coral encrusted
they're goldplated things that don't
break away with time they're still down
there but the pillar of fire melted the
shoreline of that beach where you find
out where this happened you go there the
shoreline has melted soil with rocks
infused into it Stones you can almost
see Footprints right here look at that
puddle glass puddle here you melt soil
it's going to make glass or you melt
sand it makes glass when you've got a
mix of sand and soil it makes this this
looks like a mud puddle with a rock
sticking out of it but it's melted soil
Stones infused and these guys that went
down there chipped away at it and you
can see the stones melted together like
it is a solid structure there and it
it's why science needs to get rid of
that bias the bias of getting rid of
Moses we need to bring Moses back into
the science the book that they try to
ban in all these places has proof that
it's real so much proof and Moses is
just one of those the footage is in this
presentation but this is more evidence
I'll show you real quick I didn't know
it actually play like that I forgot we
can share it this way but here's a look
at it from the beach so you can see
melted soil the only time you see stuff
like this is when you go where a volcano
erupted there's no volcanic activity
look at the stones
here water's going down I feel like you
could just see Footprints there and this
guy is standing on it right here looks
like regular Pebbles that stuff is
infused together he even takes a little
pick hammer and chips away at it I don't
know if this video is copyrighted so I
try not to show too much more but um
forbidden footage of actual location of
the Red Sea Crossing it's a long video
about 20 20 or so minutes into the vide
is where they come to this point but you
can see them taking their Journey there
and the even the people that live there
are like oh we didn't even know about
that imagine if this was a fake Missing
Link everybody would know about it oh
yeah proof of the Bible and so you don't
hear it ever I never heard about this
you find it from some YouTube video and
people are like quit getting your signs
from YouTube we're finding stuff they're
hiding from us on YouTube for a reason
you're supposed to get your information
from the controlled media propaganda
Source yeah why are you trying to think
outside the box bro yeah if the media
was lying it'd be all over the news
yeah man yeah so it's powerful stuff and
it brings us back to the Bible now that
we know that Moses can be brought back
into sign
he told us Earth was dry land but now he
talks about a firmament and he didn't
even give Earth a name until after the
firmament was made firmaments made on
day three or on day two he didn't name
Earth until day three and so that
firmament was a barrier that was able to
divide the waters and what did he call
the firmament he called it heaven so if
you wonder why you don't hear about the
firmament much later on except for like
in several places uh Daniel and other a
couple other prophets the reason why is
because he called the firmament heaven
and so you can type in the word Heaven
it's in the Bible like almost 700 times
and the Messiah uses that word more than
anybody you can type in heaven and Bible
Gateway first place about 75 times next
to him is the prophet David King David
he was 73 but he used the word firmament
twice which all if you add the two
firmament words up it equals 75 so
they're actually tied if you do it that
way but that firmament is important and
they talk about it parting like a scroll
and all these different things that are
going to happen really soon but the uh
dry land Earth sorry some of this is
repetitive but we're getting somewhere
we're going to get to the Armament yeah
I was going to say are you going to get
into breaking it down um the Genesis
account of creation and like what that
actually looks like step by step yeah I
want to try to look more of like the uh
proof we have of it but how it was
hidden why they would hide it and a
prophecy that talks about planets I know
people have questions about planets and
that's a really big one for me I grew up
loving the planets and singing the names
of those planets and one of the
prophecies in The Book of Enoch talks
about them this is chapter 80 and it's
something that really makes sense when
you hear about it and it came true you
can judge a Prophet by his prophecy and
right here he's telling them many chiefs
of the Stars Chiefs of the Stars the
brightest the planets what we call
planets are the brightest of the Stars
right he says many chiefs of the Stars
shall this is in the future they haven't
done it yet transgress the order
prescribed basically the way they were
told to go they were all given a path to
work with that perfectly functioning
clock at creation that you can look up
called wanding Stars yeah wandering
stars and it says all and these are
these shall alter their orbits and tasks
you hear that language these shall alter
their orbits and tasks and not appear at
the seasons prescribed to them and we're
taught about their orbits as if it's
this thing that's helped us figure out
the world but they shall alter those
orbits and the whole order of the Stars
shall be concealed from the Sinners and
the thoughts of those on Earth shall
Heir concerning them and they shall be
altered from all their ways yay they
shall he and take them to be gods and
evil shall be multiplied upon them wow
guess what all the planets are named
after
Gods every sing SLE one except for Earth
because Earth is just dry land they
didn't rename it but all those wondering
stars named after Roman deities Mercury
is a Roman god of speed Venus the Roman
goddess of love Mars the Roman God of
War Jupiter the Roman God of um that
they considered King of the Gods Jupiter
the biggest one the biggest Chief star
the god of the sky and thunder the
protector of Rome they weren't going to
the most high for protection they were
going to him and then Saturn the father
of of Jupiter Neptune and Pluto and then
you have Uranus there's a lot of jokes
people make there with this deity
because of his name yeah and I found out
the other pronunciation for Uranus
listen to this this is kind of comical
our anus our anus what in the world I
heard Uranus which that's not much
better Urus yeah two different
pronunciations both are bad um but he
personified the
firmament this goddess so he's the
expanse above now they're naming the
planet after him making a Graven image
you remember Enoch said they'll be taken
to be Gods that's what they've done they
assigned a star to each of these statues
each of their deities Neptune was the
Roman god of water Pluto is actually the
last name of Hades Hades Pluto the Roman
god of the underworld AKA just Hades and
so you have all these deities and as
children we're singing these songs and
the the father told us don't even utter
their names out of your mouth and we're
over there woohoo let's sing about them
we're learning we're getting wise we're
becoming worldly wise people here we're
going to go home and show our parents
not only did I learn the ABCs check this
out I know what order we are from the
Sun that wait guess what it's not a sun
it's a star and we're going around it
you know we're we're modifying the
father's truth and that truth about
those Chiefs of the stars that were in
the firmament the only structure he made
on day two of creation and this
structure when you look at the Hebrew
word it literally means to stamp out to
beat out to spread out like it is not
air if it was air and he set these Stars
the Sun the moon inside of air that
right there defies the current model of
the globe because you would be flying
planes through Stars yes our atmosphere
they say only goes up to the Carmen line
62 miles and above that is just this
vacuum of space I'm learning so much
about air pressure it's amazing because
you need this barrier to have air
pressure you can't blow up a tire if
there's a hole in it we have 14.7 psi
air pressure at sea level like we have
air pressure we have a barrier so you
talking about going through this and
that that's what I wanted to do too
because a lot of people I don't know
they how they get the the heliocentric
Globe from this but it says in the
beginning God created the Heaven and the
Earth and the Earth was without form so
no form to me that's not a ball of water
that's form no form would be like the
ocean or something right you know it's
just the water just goes wherever it
goes uh without form and void meaning
it's empty and darkness was upon the
face of the deep and the spirit of God
moved upon the face of the waters and
God said let there be light and there
was light God saw the light that was
good and God divided the light from the
darkness and God called the light day
called The Darkness light and the
evening and the morning were the first
day here's where it gets interesting and
God said let there be a firmament that
word which we don't know what it means
right now the firmament in the midst of
the waters and let it divide the waters
from the waters what Waters from the
waters I don't know and God made the
firmament to divide the waters which
were under the firmament so if a
firmament is like a glass Dome if there
is nothing but water without form and
void then you put a dome inside that
water there's air in there at this point
it's like when you take a a glass bowl
and you slide it into a filled bathtub
you can trap air under there and it says
that
there's Waters which are under the
firmament as if there was a little bit
of water still in the bottom of that
bowl and the waters which were above the
firmament now that's a question I want
to ask anyone who believes the model
that we're taught what are the waters
above the firmament I've heard some
people say no the the firmament that's
clouds that's the ozone layer that's the
atmosphere okay so maybe there's
moisture above maybe there's moisture in
the clouds moisture above the ozone
layer let's go with that and God called
the firmament Heaven sometimes we call
the sky Heaven and the evening and the
morning were the second day and God said
let the waters under the heaven be
gathered so he's bringing about the the
oceans and everything and then he's
going to bring up dry land but then it
says and God said let there be lights
where in the firmament of the heaven to
divide the day from the night and let
them be for signs and seasons and for
days and for years and which lights are
these and let them be lights in the
firmament of Heaven to give light upon
the Earth and God made two great lights
the greater light to Rule the Day the
Lesser light to rule the night and he
made the Stars also and God set them in
the firmament of Heaven to give light
upon the Earth this one verse Genesis 1
chap or Genesis chapter 1 verse
17 destroys the whole heliocentric Globe
model that we've been taught
if you believe that the firmament is the
sky or the clouds or the ozone layer or
atmosphere or any of that stuff how can
the sun the moon and the stars be in the
firmament it can't work we're told that
there's an ever expanding vacuum out
there and that the Moon is close and the
Sun is 93 million miles away and the
stars are way bigger and way further
than that in this ever expanding vacuum
of space but we're told there's water
above the firmament and that the sun
moon and stars are in that firmament how
does this
work
yeah they're there firmament still there
a lot of people say it went away with
the flood we had this barrier around the
entire Globe which then we would have
been in a submarine we would have been a
submarine globe with water around it
going around a sun would also have to be
somewhat under water except that there
is mention of the firmament
After the flood I mean it's in Proverbs
or Psalm says the firmament declares the
his handiwork right so why would you be
mentioning the firmament declares as
handiwork if it's gone we can't look to
it and say oh yep that God made it yeah
I had my students look up some verses
that indicate that it's still here and
they F they're finding some powerful
stuff and I'm like wow I never thought
about that one I mean it's just it's
interesting stuff because it's still
there and you type in the word scroll in
Bible Gateway you know you go there type
in scroll pulls up two verses one in
Isaiah one in Revelation talking about
the heavens parting like a scroll when
the return happens so yes still there
otherwise they wouldn't need to part the
the the heavens like a that's very good
point wow so powerful powerful I mean
really cool stuff and I think you guys
need to see the firmament because I had
to see it myself I was one of those
people I'm like yeah I believe it the
holy spirit's telling me it's there but
I want to actually see it I want to
reach out and see it and travel to it I
want to do all these things and the book
of tells us that it's spread out you
know he spread out the sky which is
strong as a molten Looking Glass molten
Looking Glass is magnify it takes a
curved lens to magnify I have one right
here this is a Looking Glass okay you
can use this use it as one it actually
came out of an old television but this
thing is solid Do not drop this on your
toes it's glass it's curved you can
start a fire in about I don't know three
seconds with this thing it magnifies
really really well I mean like really
really well see I can I'm so glad you
show me that because all this time I
thought a Looking Glass was a mirror so
yeah strong molten Looking Glass glass
is melted sand just like you saw our
father do at the shoreline so molten
Looking Glass that's the type of thing
you would use to read something back
then if you didn't have glasses you're
getting older you would get yourself a
curved lens that's how they make
microscope lenses and the Ancients
weren't dumb they knew how to magnify
things with a curved lens and so they
had looking glasses and that would have
been probably um a really good thing to
have like people losing their Vision at
an older age that's what you would need
a Looking Glass so they had them and
they probably used them for um
telescopes and things too they were
always studying the stars but about that
Book of Enoch I know um I do want to let
people know I know we all have different
beliefs on that book I know Mikey is a
little skeptical and cautious of that
book um I I was very very skeptical of
this book and I was listening to it just
trying to find clues about biblical
stuff and one night I'm laying there
listening to it and I hear him talk
about a phenomenon that he says he saw
because the angels are taking him on
this tour of this biblical cosmology
world and he's talking about the
firmament the lights inside it how they
change gates to change seasons and all
these things going on and one thing he
says about this phenomenon he says I saw
in regard to the Lightnings how some of
the Stars not all of them some of them
arise and become Lightnings and cannot
part with their new form and I thought
now that just sounds science fiction but
then I remembered a phenomenon known as
lightning Sprites these things that
shoot down many miles above the clouds
the clouds Peak out at about 14 miles
these things are 70 plus miles away um
they say 60 and above I don't know the
exact height and I don't think neither
do they they're making assumptions based
on this being the ionosphere that
they're coming from but I have proof
that it's not the
ionosphere it's not curved air these
things are massive and I've used a
little scale here this is from a photog
rer who there's like no clouds there
yeah the clouds would be way down here
and you're looking up above at this
barrier and something shooting down from
it and he's giving you his estimate this
is not my estimate this is his estimate
based on how high he thinks this is and
I Put a Little Rock up here Mount
Everest just to give you a scale to how
big Mount Everest will be next to these
things Mega huge powerful branching down
they look like roots of trees coming
down and they're called lightning
Sprites and the word Sprite means
disembodied spirit so whoever gave it
that name I don't know who that was um
but this is again a worldly estimate of
these things they are real they are rare
to to catch because they're so fast you
have to have special cameras just to
catch them be trying to do it but look
at these things shooting down out of the
firmament you can see they do they not
look like they're right up there with
the Stars dude this is crazy because I
the the video I've seen that you show
from Nova I couldn't tell if it was
coming out of clouds or what this is
you're looking at the stars there's no
clouds you can't see stars when it's
cloudy so what are these things what is
this coming out of yeah they're above
this little tiny little raincloud here
they're way above that yeah and it's an
electric phenomenon we have electric
aspects to our own creation our
heartbeat is electric that's why you
need electricity to get it restarted
once it uh messes up and scrambles that
electric signal you have to have those
defibrillators and shock you you are
electric you can look at nerve cells
trying to make a connection compare that
to fractal wood burning look at the
difference it's almost identical but the
footage that I came across here you're
looking at the top of the clouds on the
bottom at the very tip top here when
these lightning Sprites happen you can
see something light up there was a
barrier up above and this barrier I
thought man it look like something lit
up above this lightning Sprite let me
look at the footage and so I pulled up
the footage and you would see a ripple
because they went up above a storm in an
airplane very brave this is Nova for PBS
they were a science Network and when
they filmed it with these high-speed
cameras you could see a wave move across
this barrier and then it looked like
fireworks of lightning shooting out of
water I mean straight down and I've got
some footage here that's what I was
thinking lightning Sprite compared to a
plasma ball they almost are the same
color sometime those plasma ball labine
plasma ball lamps we used to have back
in the day I finally purchased one so I
could use it for demonstration purposes
but that's what lightning Sprites look
like and when you try to replicate them
in a lab you need a glass barrier a
strong solid barrier with a magnetic
Center
and's and and also like um what do they
call it the
Aurora what what is that like does
anybody know what that is the Aurora
lights you need a barrier to do that as
well it's like gases that are being
illuminated like a hallogen bulb right
yeah it's there's a lot of neon gases up
above us and those magnetic
electromagnetic properties of the
firmament are detectable and they're
visual are visible and those Stars
here's a screenshot I took of the video
where you could see these Sprites
shooting out and there's a barrier above
them and so we have a firmament playlist
where you can see this footage and
breakdowns of it where it goes really
slow I slow it down I adjusted the
brightness and it was listening to the
Book of Enoch that had me investigate
this and the the the footage was going
viral then my video got taken down and
they said you know it was because of
Nova and the copyright issues and I was
like well let me remake it and all of a
sudden years later the video that was
banned on YouTube comes back on my
channel they let my video come back and
I thought how am I getting comments Nova
took down their footage Nova that they
risked their lives to film going up
above a storm in a plane they took down
their original footage and so to find
the firmament footage you you'll have to
look at videos that we've made and
others have made of it from Nova but
their original historic footage of these
Sprites is gone scrubbed from the
internet can you imagine if you risked
your life to capture that footage give
it to PBS or whatever and they delete it
I mean it makes no sense why why is this
stuff being wiped away is what I want to
know like we know Google YouTube
Facebook they're all connected and
everything's so censored now the fact
Checkers and all this when I first like
started waking up in the end of 2011 man
you could find anything you could look
up on YouTube you could look up all
these conspiracy theories and there's
tons of videos about it
now if if I get on YouTube and I type
Rob skeba how do sunsets work I didn't
say nothing about shape of the Earth in
any kind of way all I get is all these
debunk videos about uh the Earth not
flat blah blah blah I'm like I'm looking
up how sunsets work by Rob skeba that's
very descriptive and yet all I'm getting
is you know Vsauce of how the Earth is a
globe or something why are they changing
the algorithm why why are they hiding
and censoring this topic why don't this
should be a red flag for any skeptic of
this topic why is it so hard just to
look at the evidence they should be
saying the powers of bees should be
saying this is such a dumb topic let
them look at it you know yeah you'll
find out it's not true no we can't trust
you to find out that it's not true
because we know you'll find out that it
is true unless we alter what you're
going to see and how is can you explain
this picture a little bit what is what
are we seeing this is from the plane
this is the footage from Nova they were
up above the storm pointing their
cameras upward and they were confused
why they kept seeing this barrier and
waves move across it and so I flipped
upside down a picture of a geyser
because when you watch them play when I
play the video on our Channel you can
see the this shooting out of it looks
like water's below the firmament almost
like there's some sort of fluid barrier
property below it and um I
thinks but you'll notice when they were
filming it stars would twinkle right
before this happened and that's how I
started going wait a minute Enoch says
they rise up and make lightning and uh
one translation says but they um do not
lose their form essentially they remain
where they are they're not falling stars
or anything they're basically rising up
and if you ever touch the top of a
plasma lamp it makes that spark with
your finger as soon as you put your hand
on it it makes that lightning spark and
these Sprites are responsible for that
lightning that's so powerful it just
obliterates trees so it's a special kind
of lightning that it makes when it
actually touches the ground and they say
it's responsible for doing a lot of
damage and that's why sometimes you'll
see somebody get struck by lightning or
a tree hit nothing really happens and
then sometimes it's like blown to
Smither it catches on fire so it's kind
of that plasma ball aspect where you can
touch it and make that spark and the
stars are somehow involved in that
process and Enoch was shown that I
believe and so that was where the Holy
Spirit Led me many years ago and people
were seeing this footage and it wasn't
making them go crazy it was making them
come to God they were coming to the
Bible they were going oh my goodness
like somebody saw it and they said I'm
just speechless I'm I've been a drug
addict for the last 13 years and I'm
going to go get a Bible today right now
I'm going to start reading it this is
true because you can see it and I know
you can't really see it in this
presentation but when you watch the
footage of it and you see how they
filmed it and them going up there
slow-mo these things shooting down out
of a barrier the ripples moving across
the firmament it's powerful and it's
literally like you can go to the our
YouTube channel and go to firmament
playlist and just all day just look at
these things the footage we have
Declassified documents and not just
lightning Sprites there's other lights
remember he put lights in the perament
of heaven and I I used this little meme
that I made years ago but I found out
when I saw a comet a couple about a
month and a half or so ago I'm trying to
remember when it was there was a comet
in the night sky my neighbors knew about
it and they were like did you know about
this Comet and I'm like what what are
you talking about and we we went to
their front porch turned around and you
can see what looked like a flashlight
shining over the horizon and I was like
that's not very bright what is this
thing this is not my picture by the way
but it looked very faint it reminded me
of somebody shining a flashlight into
the air yeah and so this Comet right
here does this not look like a
flashlight shining into the air well it
actually is a flashlight shining into
the air but that's the trick it looks
just like the comet you're look at that
look at this identical man and now I'm
gonna overlay a comet
wow that is amazing same thing a light
shining through the waters of or the
firmament and right here when you start
finding high quality photos of these
things there's Waters above the
firmament there's lights there's all
these things going on for appointed
times you can even see this light it's
shining through a barrier it almost
looks like it's shining through water
and then just pouring out light I mean
it is just gorgeous when you get high
quality photos of these things not
images but actual photos and they reveal
a lot about what's above us it's not
deep space it's not ice crystals
reflecting sunlight this stuff is easy
to prove that it's a light source
shining through a medium
they continue shining as they move
across the sky and it's for a reason and
these things were happening on holy days
this year people have been trying to
figure out the calendars and they're
going crazy trying to figure this stuff
out and I I had a friend of mine who's
like I've been doing all this advanced
math his name is George nuber he's like
I think we're a week off well the week
that was supposed to be the real Feast
of Tabernacles that Comet pops up you
know I'm just like H maybe there's some
verification here for signs and for
Seasons yeah signs and seasons and that
word Seasons means Appo times he has his
own holy days and so it's really really
cool and this is something I don't know
you you can't there's a lot of stuff
that we can't prove you know like yeah
but that's the thing like the science
Community they're
so narcissistic that they think they
have all the answers and stuff and so
when someone questions someone that
believes biblical cosmology they're like
what about this and you explain it what
about this you explain it what about
this and then you're like well I'm not
sure aha it's not right it's not true
then because you can't explain it that
doesn't really make sense
but what do you what do you think comets
are because that's probably a question
somebody would ask com yeah comets are
literally that a light in the firmament
and you can see that it's a light you
can see that there's a light source
shining through the barriers above us
and there's multi-layers I believe and
so those multiple layers with light
shining through it would look just like
this it's not a light in a vacuum and so
it is predictable it's a clock they can
predict these things most of the times
occasionally they'll get something
they're like whoa there's this new light
in the sky we don't know what it is and
so the lying signs and wonders are going
to come from above and it talks about it
in Revelation Fire coming down from
above we're seeing a lot of miniature
aspects of that now with the you know
the big rocket shows coming back down to
earth from above with fire coming down
from them like there's a lot of really
prophetic things going on now Revelation
type things and the real science though
it's it's the coolest saying when you
put the father's word to the test you're
going to find things that aren't in
science books yet and there probably
won't be in in the fake science books
that we have in schools but my my
students were investigating rainbows
because I was always in awe the fact
that in order for me to make a rainbow
inside I need a glass barrier a
flashlight water or some sort of mirror
in the water and I was like how do you
make a curved rainbow well you need a
curved glass surface and a light source
with water in it shining through and I'm
like wait a minute Rainbows are very
similar a light source being the sun in
the firmament and we've got that curved
barrier you know and it shines down and
we get these rainbows that our father
made as a covenant that he's not going
to flood the earth and the rainbow is
shaped like a dome with no holes in it
showing us he's not going to open up the
firmament again he's not going to open
the windows of Heaven the windows of
Heaven that Hebrew word for Windows it's
like a slle basically one of those if
you have a dam where they open it up to
let water out those little openings
that's a slle they hold back water
they're barriers that hold back water
and so rainbows being an an essential
ingredient to make one curved you need a
curved surface usually wow and you need
water and a light source and I thought
let me let's put this to the test and
they were doing that and they were
trying to make a rainbow with just using
the ingredients of the globe which is a
light source and water and that's it and
you're H you're having trouble you're
finding difficulty making them um
without using things that the globe
model would have or the biblical Earth
model would have and my thought was if
the Dome is higher in the middle what if
Rainbows are lower as you get closer to
the outer edges where the the firmament
is not as high places near Antarctica
and so I started looking into this this
is
like crazy I could not believe this I
went to Canada and Alaska and places
looking at rainbows and comparing them
and in Canada I was seeing some triple
rainbows that were super duper tall and
I mean just massive look at the arch the
rainbow up north and now here's
Antarctica the flattest rain rbow that
I've ever seen in my life and it was
filmed by people from the BBC when they
were filming the frozen planet and so
they went out there and filmed a flat
Rainbow near where the Dome is lower and
that to me is something that you guys
can investigate along with us I'm not
saying it's factual evidence of the
firmament but I'm saying if there's a
light in the firmament and the firmament
gets lower and closer to the ground
maybe the rainbows will be closer to the
ground it's a theory I've had and the
images I was just like impressed when I
started pulling this stuff up I was like
this is like brand new science stuff
this should be in our science books and
it probably will be just biblical Earth
there's other scientists are out there
shooting up signals and they claimed
this was back in um I forget what year
this was 2014 or somewhere around there
it was a while back these universities
this is the University of Colorado
Boulder has discovered an invisible
shield and they said they estimated they
could be wrong 7200 miles above Earth I
don't know how they got those numbers
but that's what they said and they tell
us it's almost like these electrons are
running into a last wall in space no way
that's what Baker says and he was the
lead author and he says somewhat like
the shields created by force fields on
Star Trek that were used to repel alien
weapons we are seeing an invisible
shield blocking these electrons and so
they were talking about this and they
said it is a yes A Hard fast boundary
and they publish these things and guess
what NASA comes along let me find their
article here they said oh no no no this
this is a man-made barrier we've seen it
our Pro have spotted this man-made
barrier not god-made barrier man-made
and it's wrapping around the world and
it was made by man because of all these
signals they're putting out there and so
NASA has a cover story even when what
they're hiding gets found to some degree
they have to have a cover story and you
find documents that are Declassified
from the 1950s when we allegedly had it
figured out that they are
assuming assuming it says derived their
um let's let me just read this whole
thing the near Sun halo near Sun these
these Halos are close to the Sun think
about that 98 Million Miles Away or 92
Million Miles Away they're saying near
Sun Halos and also from the Sun on a
Surface perpendicular to these Rays the
disseration contains a certain formula
of the brightness of the sky taking into
consideration only the brightness of the
first order and derived on the
Assumption of a flat
Earth talk about that here read on down
to the very bottom they are measuring
the brightness along the AL aluan of the
Sun and five to six points of the
firmament located at various in
distances so they're talking about the
assumptions of the Flat Earth and the
firmament in the same page right there
Declassified in 2000 put out there
published in
1953 yeah really cool stuff talking
about it they knew about it um me see
what that slide is right there there you
go but the Van Allen belts essentially
were a cover story for the
famentera
astronauts didn't even know about it
when they were interviewed later by
people questioning the authenticity of
the moonlanding and they say well um
they didn't affect us and I don't even
think they'd been discovered yet you
know like they're saying these things as
if well if we went through it surely we
accounted for it well they had to have
gone through it because it was a
distance less distance than the moon so
they passed right through it went to the
moon came back many times playing golf
dancing around didn't care weren't
worried about it and so that barrier is
a cover story to keep us from going back
to the Moon keeping us trapped in what
they call low earth orbit and we're not
going around a ball they're going up as
high as they can go rocket ships
pointing back down peacefully guarding
this place the ice the circle of the dry
land the circle of the Earth around us
called Antarctica and they've been
guarding it peacefully think about that
since 1959 all these world powers
studying ice how long can you study ice
right like how long and they' studied it
for years and years and years and years
and they're still doing it peacefully
and and the Antarctic treaty isn't set
to expire until the 2040s and it doesn't
really expire they're just going to kind
of like revamp it probably and put in
more measures in place if the return
hasn't happened but the two things for
anybody that this is like their first
time time ever hearing any of this stuff
they don't understand the model or
anything why would why is there some
treaty that you can't go to
Antarctica yeah yeah why why why can't
we go there we can go up North 60th
North parallel I'm asking you like what
would be kind of the answer like oh the
answer because if you were to explore
you would find out that Shoreline it's
not an 11,000 mile circumference there's
definitely some more land out there I'm
not going to say it's an infinite plane
I can tell that the firmament goes
downward as you get close to Antarctica
there are outer boundaries The Book of
Enoch talks about them these mountains
these resources out there I mean so
mountains these individual mountains
that are made of materials that would be
worth zillions of dollars and the man
himself Admiral bird the one that was
doing the operations back then high jump
and deep freeze he says there's
mountains of coal there he's kind of
verifying some of the things in Enoch
he's like yeah there's these it's a
treasure Trove it's a very rich place of
these things and resources and I'm
thinking wow these countries should be
fighting over that there's an energy
crisis right and now let's just close it
down after he says that it gets closed
off no one's allowed to go there there's
the Antarctic treaty NASA forms
operation Fishbowl happens operation
high jump or not high jump operation
Dominic and Fishbowl were pretty much
the same operation there fish which is
what they're trying to launch rockets to
hit the Dome and yeah they said that
when they shot nuclear bombs up to the
um as high as they could go near the
ionosphere they caused an aurora light
oh what why would shooting a bomb into
the air cause an aurora light if you're
shooting it up where deep space is
because that's what they were aiming for
seeing how it would affect the ion spere
and communication allegedly that's a
really dumb reason to shoot bombs into
the air let's see how it affects the the
air above us you know like this is the
modern day Tower of Babel like the god
destroyed a building a tower that was
going too high up and and now man is
like you know what we're not going to
build a building we're going to ignite
Rockets into the sky and I think they
want to escape you know
because the serpent in the garden that
was his whole lie was that you're in in
a prison that Yahweh has put you in this
Garden prison and he's trying to keep
you from evolving and and so you know
the heart of man is desperately wicked
and if we if these elitists think
oh there's something more out there you
know and we are in a a prison they're
going to try to blast that thing and
it's pretty crazy to think about what
they're trying to do because if they
were able to blast it which I don't
think they can it would just flood the
whole world would the windows of Heaven
would be opened up right yeah and and
they just stopped instantly once they
set up a big bomb they said oh they they
just shut down the operation they said
oh we ran out of funding and they quit
doing it and so the most high laughs at
the things they're doing like it's not
they they can't do it he knew what they
were going to try to do before they
tried to do it when he was making the
firmament on day two of creation and
that's why when he was talking in
Genesis 11 when he's talking about what
they're going to do what they're trying
to do he said for one it's not
impossible if they're trying to reach
the firmament it's not impossible if
they're United they have the same
language but then he says this is only
the beginning of what they will do
nothing that they proposed to do will
now be impossible for them and so that's
only the beginning he didn't say oh
they're going to do this I'm going to
send them out and that's going to fix it
he says this is only the beginning and
so that sounds like he knows they're
planning to do more they're going to be
shooting bombs up they're going to be
creating these lies that people are
going to believe and a lot of the things
in Revelation the arm Ed the threat from
above uniting people to fight against a
threat you have to believe there's a
threat from above you can't believe in
the you got to believe in aliens now
Congress is saying aliens are real oh
we've got B we've got specimens and
they're non-human origin and they have
these Technologies and slowly admitting
these things to get the mystery of it
and for us to be like I was right I
believed in Aliens my whole life I
watched Unsolved Mysteries from the 80s
to the 90s and you know I've been a
space fan ever since like I was a space
fan I Lov N Stuff I was I I mean like
watching the STS rocket launches and the
the dam dramatic you know how they
dramatized it you know the shaking the
you know yeah then you get older and
it's like oh my goodness space movies
are everywhere now and I I would watch
the Martian with my classroom I started
teaching science my first day on the job
they handed me a globe and said hey
you're taking over this class because I
got kind of thrown into really cool
situation where it was Earth Science
imagine that my very first ever teaching
gig after starting out trying to get my
certification after college and they
said we're doing the coris effect here's
a blowup Globe here's a dry racee marker
have at it and so I was I was doing that
back then and it's it's really cool the
father's grace and mercy starting me out
that way just to show me stay humble
this was you you know you were SP you
love this stuff you believed this stuff
you were excited about it it seemed
innocent and now you're finding out it's
not innocent it's against his truth it's
Tower of Babel 2.0 and so be careful
when you see the world powers agreeing
on stuff but I want to kind of move on
because I don't want to take up too much
time I know there's a lot of questions
seen curvature have you seen this um
encyclopedia from
19 what time when was it oh man
encyclopedia
from oh Britannica the 50 or is it like
the 1950s 53 May yeah 1958 encyclopedia
britanica from
1958 talks about what it says it doesn't
it say there's like you can the
structure like a dome like structure
13,000 feet high when they were
exploring out there right latitude like
they tell you where it's at on them like
how far out it is and it's out there
beyond the ice wall that they had to go
go over with operation high jump and
when you look at these places there's
places called dome in Antarctica lots of
places called Dome how many places
called Dome a lot there's even a
Deception Island right when you get to
the start of it Deception Island and a
bunch of places called Dome and I
started looking into it and all those
places are flat why would you name a
place Dome Dome a dome B Dome C that's
weird dud it's like that's kind of fishy
when we believe in that and you're
naming places after that and there's a
masonic lodge down there and there's you
know it's like it's weird
so this would they this screenshot is
from a video if you can look it up
yourself on bitshoot it's not going to
be on YouTube of course for some reason
but look up 1958 encyclopedia Dome and
the guy shows the book he shows all the
copyright and all that opens it up and
the what the word he's looking up here
it might be anarctica I can't remember
what he's looking up but or it's
firmament or something but when you read
it it says with a dome 13,000 feet high
and it says the longitude and latitude I
mean it's it's crazy yeah I've never saw
a mountain and said oh look a dome you
know if there was a dome structure that
high that would be pretty it would be on
a map and go to Antarctica on a map go
to that place where it lifted the
latitude and longitude it's flat it's a
cartoon it's a flat cartoon a place that
we've been studying for decades we don't
even have aerial photos of it on Google
Maps but everywhere else we do why is
that one place stitched together like a
quilted cartoon from I mean Nintendo 64
Ed better with their Graphics like it's
it's pitiful wow and so that was that's
Antarctica it's it's mysterious they
want it to be that way they don't want
you to go there 14 I forget how many
thousands of dollars back when I first
tried to get a trip there because I was
wanting to go there my my wife likes to
travel it's like let's go to Antarctica
this will be fun you know here it is
2018 2017 and she's like how much is it
$40,000 oh my good one way I was like
well I guess we can't go that's what I'm
make in a year almost you know like
can't do that so that easy way to keep
people from exploring right yeah the
wealthy will go yeah they're already
part of a club what were you showing in
the previous slide first picture here
curvature we've all seen the curve I
grew up seeing it um daily it's in every
single photo from high altitudes and
yeah they you see stuff like this
because of a certain lens but you also
see it warping in the other direction
which actually proves that it's flat
because you can only bend a a flat
Horizon both directions a curved line
you can't bend it both ways perfectly
and so there's tests you that the
Horizon is in the upper half of the
photograph if the Horizon was in the
lower half of the photograph it would be
bending the other way it'd be concave
but all these pictures the horizons and
the the upper half of the photo which is
bending it with that fishy lens yeah
classic fishe lens trickery there you
can make any flat surface curved and so
that's what's been done and you can
debunk the curve by using a fishe lens
and trying to make a curved line Bend
perfectly both ways can't do it I've
tried same with lasers you can debunk
the curved water aspect with a laser
we've had lots of people doing this my
friend Ben from taboo conspiracy and one
of his buddies from Fe core I trying to
remember his name I think it was Matt
got a tripod went across a lake 21 miles
meaning that their tripod should have
been 218 feet tall to see the laser was
right above the water just five feet
above the water and not only could you
see the laser and they say it's the
laser curving around does this laser
light look curved oh my goodness going
in a straight line and you can see the
reflection on the water as well so if
that was reflection on the water they're
seeing the reflection on the water would
have to jump up and go around the curve
straight up 90 degrees and then curve
around along with this laser and then
drop below it and look like it's a
reflection on the water you can't have
that if the laser can curve okay maybe
it can lasers can curve in certain
mediums but not the reflection on the
water because you wouldn't be able to
see that so you can see both and I had
to adjust the brightness they do this at
night there's a lot of water in our air
to cut through the um laser will spread
out and that water aspect is huge
because when you watch a sunset you've
been able to stare at it with your eyes
without sunglasses when it sets at a at
a beach it's an orange glow it's
beautiful you can watch it go down try
doing that at noon you'll go blind why
because we're staring through a 60 mile
high um we're underwater you know we got
all this air and water stacked up on top
of us it's like we're in a swimming pool
of air it has its limits its density it
can only stack up so high and so we
can't see very far because we're staring
through water just like you can't see
the bottom of the ocean right people say
well you can't see the sun it goes dark
that means the world's a globe you can't
see the bottom of the Maran trench from
the surface that doesn't mean that the
ocean is all curved right there in
between you and the ocean sea floor it's
just there's water filtering out light
submarines need lights for a reason
sunlight will only go so far so we have
our limitations and you see that with
lasers they kind of can only go about 25
miles or so I think 25 miles is the
record maybe a little further than that
now but line of sight um signal or not
line of sight signals um eyesight
records have gone beyond this right here
but this is just a good photo to show
you that your Horizon at a camera height
of 1 foot 12 Ines off the ground should
be 1.2 miles away but they saw these two
oil rigs one of them is 9.4 miles away
where's the Horizon it's behind that
behind it behind something that's
impossible for the Horizon 2 scorpion
upwards and appear behind something when
it should be in front of it you should
not be able to see this thing right here
and so right here got the measurements
for you and that's the cool thing about
biblical earth scientists they give you
all the numbers you don't have to wonder
what the numbers are they show you how
far away things are using that 66 feet
per mile squared formula and you can do
the math and the curve is not there
sometimes it may appear to be there due
to the magnification properties of water
but world record photos right here
missing 3/4 of a mile
wow of curvature three4 of a mile if
you've ever ran three4 of a mile imagine
that being stacked straight up that's
how much curvature curvature should be
between you and this these mountains in
the distance
making them Smoky eventually they're
going to disappear into that water and
so visibility will change with moisture
and that that's just a known science
it's not a conspiracy you can look that
up sometimes you can see right in front
of your face in the morning I'm driving
to work I can't see in front of my car
two feet because there's fog it's water
in the air and so that's a small scale
version of what we see in this large
scale picture here world records and
here's another really far one right here
45 and a half miles so how much that
should be hit by and so really really
far seeing all the way to cre from
Israel large distances but that's just
line of sight people can say refraction
back in 1901 googly Elmo Marone sent a
line of sight signal and if you don't
know what that is it's a signal like a
radio signal that doesn't curve it only
goes in a straight line physicist told
him it's going to be impossible don't
even try to go across the Atlantic the
Earth curvature will stop that signal
and this guy must have known something
cuz cuz he said I'm going to do it
anyways I'm going to crank up the power
and he made that signal cross the
Atlantic 2100 miles that's 5504 miles of
missing curve that's that was back in
1901 do you think we've gone further
since then wow bro we have we've gone
from England to
Australia in 1918 England to Australia
with what to Australia radio signal yep
tower height 500 meters the tower would
have needed to be 38
M
59632 ft tall or 7,310 miles tall to
make that so what are the excuses what
are people saying that why why this
happen refraction it's bouncing it's
bouncing off of the ionosphere hundreds
of times off of a gas barrier and these
things they don't bounce they just go in
a straight line and
so that would even prove a firmament if
it's bouncing off something I mean
bouncing off of a barrier above us so
curvature or not it would need a
firmament and so they're saying
refraction I and nobody really talks
about this one when I bring this one up
they're like oh well you had to use
Google Maps you know like they just they
kind of deflect but that is possible on
a Biblical Earth sending signals that
far and reading old papers about this
they say there was a radio roof what
they called a radio roof where when the
sun excuse me the sun would come out
it's like it would mess up their ability
to communicate so when the sky turns
blue and it's electrified with that
sunlight it's like a neon light it turns
blue and so they said it's like a radio
roof it's like somebody breathed the
breath Over The Ether they called it The
Ether back then and The Ether used to be
in the periodic tables and now they
removed it and so it's it's really
really interesting the things they're
doing but the proofs are stacking up not
just line of sight signals we have
Polaris which never moves go out there
point something at it it it'll be
pointing at it all year long and there's
a star on a Ryan's Belt that the
Ancients they lined up their pyramids
with that's why the pyramids are usually
coming in threes right here they
worshiped oy look at the pose he's
making does that not look like the
Statue of Liberty and all of these
things got the hand in the air the left
foot forward baffet POS is like that
they're always like that saan summoning
his Legion so they worshiped oan that's
why NASA now has their oion spacecraft
and so it's a big part of their worship
and the cool thing about this one star
it stays on the equator all year so if
you have one star staying on the equator
all year one star moving all year that's
two points of reference that are
stationary throughout the year and so to
me that proves we're not going around
the sun on a tilting ball and all these
different directions it's impossible
with those points of reference there and
you can see that even star trails with a
graph here showing you remember half a
million miles per hour that's how fast
we're going through the Galaxy because
of the Big Bang invented by a Jesuit
priest and we're going around the Sun at
66,000 milph or
66,6 and so the green represents our big
bang explosion speed 8,000 miles per
minute okay so think about that if
you're going almost 8,000 miles a
minute that is really really really fast
and so every minute every minute every
60 seconds the Earth would go the
distance of its own diameter with that
speed then around the sun right here at
second fastest motion still shows up on
the graph then you get to our spin it's
puny tiny little dotted line here
however when you look at star Trails
which of those speeds do you think would
impact the night sky the one where
you're moving the distance of your own
diameter every minute no 16 and half
miles a minute right here that's what
makes perfect circles not spirals not
weird shapes because of all those other
speeds don't worry about those your
slowest motion that's what makes perfect
circles that's what affects the night
sky they tell us W and so the speeds are
really really fast hundreds of times
faster than a bullet it's a roller
coaster type motion go ahead can I show
something I want to show because this
this made me think a lot when I was
looking into this subject okay so this
is this is Earth's orbit around the Sun
at different times of the year and I
don't know if you can see my mouse but
picture you're at this one on the far
right if you're on Earth and you're
looking at the night sky at the stars
you would have to look right at night
time because night time is always going
to be the opposite side of the Sun so
during this time of the year this is
winter it says Northern hemispher and
winter you're always having to look
towards the right now imagine you're on
that Earth and now it is late June it's
on the far left side which way are you
having to look at the stars at night now
you're having to look to the left so how
are you ever going to see the same stars
in December when you have to look to the
right and now you're on the other side
of this gigantic ball of light that's a
thousand times bigger than Earth it's 93
million miles away from Earth and now
you're on the other side of it and
you're having to look at stars the
opposite direction how could you ever
see the same Stars year round yeah put
that to the test do what that look at
this illustration Mikey has go outside
look up at the night sky for six months
that's what I I thought I'm gonna be on
the other side of that sun if this is a
heliocentric model yeah I never got to
the other side of the Sun and saw the
stars on the other side and I asked one
of my co-workers I said why don't we see
the stars on the other side of the sun
she's like I don't know and I was like H
good I don't either oh well move along
next question so yeah I think it's it's
very important to test that stuff for
yourself go look at the stars see if
we're every six months we're looking the
other direction and they'll say oh we're
really small doesn't matter how small
you are I can't see the wall behind me
for a reason because I'm facing this
Direction that's right so uh right here
just some little verses for the biblical
crew um the world is immovable you can
look that up 1st Chronicles 16:30 all
throughout the Psalms 1 Samuel and I
mean just everywhere in the word that
world being immovable never being placed
in motion and like my dad said and it
just stuck the Earth is God's foot stol
it's not his roller coaster it's an
immovable he's not riding around
following a moving world it is a foot
stol and look at a foot stol it has
pillars you know it has that Dome shape
to it that barrier something you can sit
your feet on and so he's above that
Circle of the Earth it's like a foot
stol and so foot stools don't move and
roller coasters no matter how slow you
go on this thing with these spiraling
motions even if you're not rotating just
sitting in a seat you're going to fill
it and so we're not on a train a lot of
people like to use the train analogy
throw a ball up on a train okay a train
has a barrier the Train's going in a
straight line we're on a pressurized
ball in a vacuum chamber with an air
pressure of 14.7 PSI moving half a
million miles per hour hundreds of times
faster than a bullet I think 8 times
faster than a bullet just try to picture
living on a bullet that's spiraling and
going 288 times faster than that bullet
doing the same thing in a vacuum chamber
life itself would be a miracle you'd
have to admit okay if that were true if
it were a big bang heliocentric model
there has to be some sort of intelligent
designer that's like H I'm a master
engineer how can I solve the problem of
a ball in a
vacuum and make people live on it make
it covered with water make the water
stick to it while it's doing doing all
these roller coaster things how can you
have how can you have a ball in a vacuum
and there be a pressure like air oxygen
air pressure on this Earth that we can
breathe but when you fly up up up up
eventually pop you pop out and you're
weightless like where is that barrier
why does it happen oh gravity it's
always like you know the the secret
answer is always gravity no matter what
but yeah why is gravity pushing ox o to
Earth all the time I don't know if
you're going to get into the concept of
that's a beautiful thing oxygen I should
have included some of that in this
presentation because I've been learning
about this stuff and you have to think
of creation from there was a master
engineer designing things to support his
most precious creation and that's life
itself you guys are his most precious
creation hands down you could not offer
him a mountain of gold for one of his
elect you can't bribe him you are more
important to anything to him what does
the Bible say his inheritance is we're
all concerned about where we go what's
his inheritance his people that's his
inheritance he's waiting to meet you
guys and so I get emotional thinking
about it because my whole life I've been
programmed to what about me what what
about my inheritance what am i g to get
oh I'm G to be a joint Heir with the
Messiah That's good I've been a nice
person no we're his inheritance he's our
inheritance him and being reigning with
his son something we don't deserve to do
joint HS with the Messiah like it tells
like it's it's a powerful inheritance
and so I mean it's just you guys are
important so when he's making his
creation he's going to make it sustain
life he's going to make the air that we
breathe not have the same properties as
helium imagine if he messed up he wasn't
that good of an engineer and the air we
needed had the same density as helium
you can look at the densities of the air
we breathe it's more dense than helium
and it's the dense air that Stacks up
right from the ground up and it's going
to stack up to a certain height that's
that's why helium balloons max out at 33
miles they can't go higher than that
they they don't float in vacuum Chambers
if you put a balloon in a vacuum chamber
it'll float until it reaches a vacuum
and then it sinks and so imagine that
vacuum chamber being like a swimming
pool the helium balloon is in that
swimming pool floating right you take
out what it's floating on the air it's
going to sink down and so helium
balloons only go until they reach the
tippy top of our air they can't go any
higher and they have a level where they
stop they cannot float in a vacuum so it
is essentially kind of like a vacuum
above us but it's really not it has
helium it has the hydrogen gases all
those less dense gases that we don't
breathe and our gases stack up from the
level where we live the sea level all
the way above Mount Everest he knew
where his dry land was he knew the outer
limitations we don't need air above that
that's healthy enough to breathe because
we're not going to be living up there he
knew when he designed the quantity of
air that we needed how much to put in
there in our world to where it would
cycle and so he knew that when he made
you know he made plants before he made
people he made plants on day three they
made the air that we would need to
continue having our life sustained of
course he gave us that initial start
with the Breath of Life which has kept
everything in this Perpetual miraculous
motion and so helium only goes so high
but when you look it up and try to find
out well what happens to helium while
we're running out of it they say oh it
gets sucked into the vacuum of space
well if it doesn't float in a vacuum and
it's on top of our air
why is it getting sucked away and why is
the vacuum of space going I only suck up
helium I don't suck up other air I'm G
to stop with helium like why would it
stop with helium helium doesn't float in
a vacuum yeah why is it just sucking
that up and so there's
gasi gravity at all or not really going
to get into gravity there's a lot of
density aspects and you saw those
electromagnetic properties of the
firmament that's really in advanc
science lesson yeah but essentially
things Stack Up based on their density
that's why Hydro um s's it called um
sulfur I'm trying to remember the name
of the gas I'm forgetting my my gases
here um let me look it up real quick I
want bring while you're looking that up
I want to bring up a point that maybe
somebody's thinking about um we're told
that gravity is a force that pulls
things down to the core of the earth no
matter where you're at on this ball it's
it's forcefully pulling things to the
core and that's why we're stuck on this
Earth even though it's spinning at a
th000 miles an hour we're not getting
thrown off of it so ask yourself the
question how come when you let go of a
helium balloon it doesn't drop to the
ground it should it's super light if
this is a force that's literally pulling
things to the ground it can hold um dump
trucks and buildings and oceans to this
ball that's spinning so fast we should
all be flying off of it why does a
helium balloon go up why does a
butterfly not just fall to the ground
why does a dandelion float in the air
because it's not a force that's like
saying and people will say well because
it's it's too light that's like saying
Arnold Schwarzenegger is so strong that
he can push a train car but he can't
lift a balloon it makes absolutely no
sense so what's happening with this
theory of gravity it is it is a theory
you can look it up it's not a fact it's
a theory of gravity a well accepted one
but we're talking about buoyancy and
density we're talking about gases and
the way they stack up and that's what
makes helium go up because it's lighter
than air and we've heard that all our
life that helium floats because it's
lighter than air but that defies Gravity
the whole idea that gravity is this
Force pulling things to the Center of
the Earth yeah and and helium has it's a
known density and I was buying helium
balloons and when you scan your items at
self checkout it says put the item on
the scale and I was buying a helium I'm
like I don't know how to do that and so
that has a density though
71785 G per liter at sea level our air
has a density of 1.22 G per liter at sea
level and so a balloon that's got air in
it is going to weigh more than a balloon
that doesn't have air in it but a
balloon that has helium is going to be
floating up on that air as if the air is
water and it's a boat you know it's
going upward and so things stack up from
sulfur hexafluoride that's the name of
the gas I was trying to think of that's
the one if you breathe it in which I
find this fascinating you breathe in
Sulfur hexl
your voice gets real deep you breathe in
hel Which is less dense than air your
voice gets real high pitch I think
that's fascinating that the two are like
opposites one's going downward it's it's
going to find its lowest point you can
fill up a tank with sulfur heop floride
and invisible gas you can't see it take
a boat made out of aluminum foil you can
make it float on sulfur hexafluoride it
looks like it's defin gravity you can't
see the silver hexafluoride it's there
but it floats on top of it remove and
takes that sulfur hexif fluide pour it
into the boat it's going to sink just
like you're pouring water in it and so
that sulfur hexif floride that's why you
find it way down deep in Ocean
hydrothermal vents because it's gone
down it sinks down into the world it
keeps going downward it's not like the
oxygen that our father Master engineered
to go where his created life lives and
trees make that and it doesn't float off
like helium when trees make it it goes
to his beloved Creations W so he's a
master designer and when you start
seeing it like that makes sense why he
made it the density that he made it why
he made the water that we need for life
to float defy gravity float up trillions
of pounds of water just went over our
heads yet the other day when it was
raining trillions I'm talking to my
students on the other side of the
country and they're like yeah there's
it's all cloudy and rain's coming down
I'm like you do realize we have
trillions of pounds of water moving
across the sky to find gravity and
nobody cares it's just like that's crazy
dude yeah our father designed it that
way at he designed it he had to engineer
it to do what it does to give us life to
give us water to give us air and it's we
can't even do it like the cells in the
water the algae they are solar powerered
they can use sunlight to make food and
they can make oxygen like imagine if we
were like hey guys this inventor just
made a solar panel that makes oxygen we
don't need trees anymore we don't need
electricity like that's what his
creation can do it's extremely extremely
Advanced powerful stuff and like it just
I Marvel at it I mean it's really it's
it's it's really cool how much thought
he put into his creation and the
biblical Earth model even after the
flood having properties where you see it
opening up and we read that because
remember he called the firmament Heaven
yeah and that's where you start seeing
stuff like this little story here I
missed this one where he's being
baptized he's got witnesses that see
this people go why didn't Jesus talk
about the the Flat Earth well because
Earth is just just dry land it's not
really flat so he didn't have to use
those words but it says it came to pass
when he was getting baptized that Jesus
also being baptized and praying imagine
that the Messiah praying showing us how
to live while he's being baptized he's
praying he's in the middle of praying
while he's being baptized talking to his
father the heaven was opened that
firmament was opened and the Holy Ghost
descended and a bodily shape like a dove
upon him and so he didn't need to stop
and go hold on guys guys I know y'all
believe in the globe the firmaments
opening up I'll explain later no they
believed in the biblical Earth model
they weren't shocked you never hear one
account of somebody going oh my goodness
I believed in the globe what's this
expanse opening up no they believed in
the Bible they knew that he called that
F Heaven that it was still there the
windows of Heaven were closed and to
close a window you need a wall attached
to them or some sort of barrier and so
he didn't need to give them a science
lesson but he did tell them guys he said
guys the days of Noah were so shall also
the coming of the son of man be yeah
he's telling them about the days of Noah
and if you look back to Noah he was a
conspiracy theorist until The Fountains
of that firmament up above us were
opened yeah and all those rains started
pouring down not the rain but the water
from the firmament above that he
separated with day two of creation
lifting those Waters up they were coming
down very similar to Noah us being in
those days of Noah they're corrupting
All Flesh biblical Earth Believers
people that still believe in the Bible
will be called conspiracy theorists just
like Noah until that firmament opens
when he returns Parts like a scroll
every eye sees him not an image of him
on a tablet not some technological
advancement no every eye will see him
when he returns and so that's possible
because the biblical Earth model is real
the heaven is going to part and if
there's still waters above the firmament
he's not going to flood the Earth those
waters are going to part and it's
probably why when he set his people free
he parted the waters and when they were
brought into the promised land he parted
the waters so the most high is capable
of doing just that parting the waters
parting the firmament and so it's a
powerful Journey there's so much proof
out there but put it to the test I
encourage all of you don't take our
words for it I know we get called Bible
Thumpers and all these different things
and science deniers that's okay you know
think of us as that but put it to the
test and you're going to find out the
word of our father will hold up to any
test you throw at him the wisdom of this
world is going to fall away its
foolishness for that reason and so First
Corinthians
318-19 that's what we encourage all of
you to do and become Fools With Us put
it to the test it's fun but you are GNA
lose a lot of street cred all the people
that think you're wise because I
remember nobody thought I was foolish as
H it's was like okay now you're just
really like all of a sudden you just
lost IQ points no matter yeah what your
is no matter who you are no matter what
you've done we have literal doctors and
and people working at universities who
are right there being called fools and
they're in documentaries and oh speaking
of documentaries um let me tell you this
because I forgot about that there's a a
good documentary coming out this
Saturday I think it's Saturday I could
be wrong I think it might be Friday
night or Saturday I have to look um
there's a documentary coming out on
YouTube it's already out on Amazon it's
already out on um the Roku Channel and
it's a Biblical cosmology documentary
and my brother and I were in it and a
bunch of other people were in it people
that work at universities and it's
called Origins Untold ancient cosmology
and so it's a really really really good
one well done high quality it's not
forceful it's not mean just giving you
some good talking points kind of the
stuff we're talking about tonight and
they're following the Journey of a
skeptic a guy who really was he's not
one of us a Believer like us back then
he was a legit skeptic going into it
he's like all right if you guys want me
to do this documentary I'll do it and
I'll go through and I'll ask people
questions but I'm not going to buy into
it right away I'm going to actually look
into it for myself and so that's what
he's been doing and it's really high
quality film Origins Untold it'll be
available on YouTube for those of you
who are using YouTube I hope I'm
assuming most of you are now but that's
what it's G available on um this weekend
and so we're going to be going live and
I need I wish I had my phone with me so
I could see the time there it is Origins
Untold ancient cosmology
awesome this is gonna be this is on so
it's not out yet but it will be on Roku
and it will be on it is on the Roku
channel it's already on the Roku so if
you're at home and you want to watch it
on the Roku it's there Roku Channel you
can even go on the website the Roku
channel.com and look it up Origins
Untold ancient cosmology um and I
believe Amazon Prime has it so it's a
good one to share with loved ones I mean
watch it yourself if you still have
questions and so if you guys have
questions now I'd love to answer some
before we have to go definitely I see
some people in here that
you know one one lady saying that her
husband doesn't believe in his stuff and
she's trying to figure out how to convey
some of this scientific talk you're
saying to him but this would be a great
date night movie Origins Untold because
it's coming from the eyes of a skeptic
so it it's kind of like you get to weigh
out the evidence that's what I love to
do on this channel I love to look at all
the evidence and and weigh it out
whether it's the topic of the Rapture
whether it's the topic of what happens
when you die or any of these topics I
want to look at okay here's all the
verses that they say and here's all the
verses that say something else let's
study it out and so I think we don't
even have to go into giving the evidence
for the globe model because we've all
been indoctrinated knowing it you know
and learning all these things so we're
just looking at what does a Bible say
what does science say and man I
appreciate you so much coming on here
and sharing what you've got with us and
I'm sure we'll do some more talks about
it I wanted to promote again your um
your Bible school or your science class
for homeschoolers or whoever wants to be
in it there's no age limit right you can
be an adult and do this yeah well our
two we have essentially two younger age
classes um Earth's Foundation that's our
biggest class that is Earth science for
it's it was originally based on like
sixth grade standards but you can be any
grade you know my daughter's second
grade she's in my class second grade
sometimes it just depends on what you
the younger they get the less you're
able to use because it it's it's geared
towards you know Elementary to middle
school age students but our firmament
breakdown class is our other earth
science class and you can be high school
college 80 90 whatever wherever you want
to start your Learning Journey with this
stuff and we've got parents going down
sitting down with their their children
learning and we have people that are
post colle coming in taking classes and
so we have people of all ages and it's
been a major blessing best students I've
ever had we have fun together we laugh
together we are learning things we're
praying together they took prayer out of
school and we've been fortunate to to
bring it back and so it's it's been a
blessing and our two life science
classes are also a blessing I have intro
to intelligent design which is again
more of like a middle school life
science class and then we have our
biological design which is a high school
biology you're going to learn everything
you learn in high school biology from an
intelligent design perspective without
bias destroying Evolution so there's a
little bit of bias there I mean we're
biased against the wisdom of the Fallen
there the the ones who said separate
Moses from science we're g to get rid of
that that concept and bring Moses back
bring back the proofs of the Red Sea
Crossing and it's funny I got observed
last year teaching that lesson where I
was talking about the Red Sea Crossing
and how this guy I was showing what I
showed you guys about uh Charles Lyall
and his we got to remove Moses from
science that guy talking about him and
how we have proof of the Red Sea
Crossing that was my next slides and my
principal walked right in the room with
his clipboard and was like all right
show what you got I'm like oh really I
was like oh hey how's it going have a
seat then uh my heart started racing I
was like I'm about to get fired because
this was like a week after he sat me
down and said you don't need to have
bias when you're doing your lessons and
I was like you would come in on the one
day where i'm really doing this the way
that you know and I'm not saying hey
guys you got to believe in the Bible you
know I'm just saying here's scientific
evidence of the pillar of fire you know
not in our textbooks I just want you to
see it not going to see it in the
textbook but it's there so yeah it's
been fun it's been a blessing it's been
a lot of work
yeah so the big question everybody has
why the lie why would they lie about the
shape of the earth why would they do
that it doesn't even make sense why is
this a salvational issue like isn't this
just a distraction I mean this is some
rabbit hole why don't you just focus on
Jesus man yeah and so
you want to give your answer I mean I
think gospel message the gospel of the
Kingdom of Heaven you know this Kingdom
of Heaven Kingdom of Heaven my Father in
heaven in heaven in heaven you know it's
like there's always this Heaven aspect
he's above he's the most high because
there's a height there's a height to
Heaven you know so there's a lot of
things that have to do with end time
deceptions and they can't fake this
threat from above if we believe in the
firmament and we know the returns
happening and we believe in the word
they can't deceive us the way they have
they can't separate us from the most
high with their Infinite Space they
can't have Evolution all of their
demonic lies and I think most people can
agree that evolution is a demonic lie us
coming from and it's in school textbooks
it's scientists say it all around the
world so they all agree on it yeah
people think how could how could this be
one giant conspiracy where every
scientist every rocket scientist is
involved well I mean you could say the
same thing about Evolution I mean it's
yeah it's in every textbook it's on
every you know History Channel or
Discovery Channel or whatever are they
all in on the LIE no they've all just
been indoctrinated themselves and
they're
regurgitating the the wisdom that they
got from this world yeah the fullish
wisdom so West bla says it's the setting
for the whole story yeah West bl's a
Bible scholar that's right super awesome
brother right there with a I saw geot
truth as well George
nuber the man the math the legend he
hates when I say that so what I believe
they're doing is yeah like like Josh
said you cannot have big bang EV
darwinian Evolution and ultimately the
final deception that I believe is
Satan's final Opus the final masquerade
is an alien invasion we I've been
believing this since 2012 that Satan is
going to deceive the whole world through
a pretending to be a visitor From
Another World demons literally saying
that they're visitant from other worlds
and and getting it to the point where
we're embracing them like yeah don't
don't judge them don't you dare call
them demons they're just our our space
Brothers but we could never believe that
there'd be visitants from other worlds
if we knew where we lived if we knew
that there is a firm moment that's hard
like a vault and like molent looking
glass that divid hides Waters above the
waters there's nothing but water up
there when you look at stars up close
not from NASA look on go on YouTube and
look up telescope stars real stars or
something these things look like lights
underwater they are flickering and
changing color and it literally looks
like an LED light bulb in a water it's
proving that the Bible's true that these
are lights in the firmament but all of
this deception is it a Salvation issue
that's what people ask
is the mark of the beast a Salvation
issue is the final deception that's
going to deceive the whole world a
Salvation issue
absolutely can you believe in the globe
and not fall for the final deception yes
you can you can understand that aliens
are not really aliens and they're demons
and you could not fall for it but how
much more would you not fall for it if
you knew exactly where you lived and
you're like there's no way this is a
deception nobody can come from space
because space isn't what we think it is
it doesn't exist there's a there's a
glass Dome up there nothing can come in
nobody would fall for the lie so Satan
has had to create this lie to set the
stage for his last
act yeah well
said the stage has been set they're
talking about aliens in the news right
now who are you going to believe the
government now now they're oh now
they're telling us the truth because
they have to the good guys are putting
them under the microscope here make it
them speak about alien no the alien
stuff Warner Von brn one of the na Nazi
NASA scientists that doesn't sound
politically correct but that's what he
was he came straight from Nazi Germany
as a Nazi scientist to NASA one of their
Founders and this guy warned before he
died they're planting a fake alien
threat it's all a lie to pretend to
weaponize space which isn't real because
he put a verse about the firmament on
his tombstone he knows about but he said
planning this threat it's all based on
lies and now that we know that's their
final card it makes sense to be their
final thing if the millennial reain
kicks off like what else can you do
you're the enem is bound you can't be
pulling off more deceptions after that
so that's their final card that's it
that's what they're trying to weaponize
space for that's why they're sending all
these things allegedly up there and
putting lights in the sky so that we see
their lights and Marvel at their their
lights and starlink and all these things
and yeah it's all a deception it's all
it's all lying signs and wonders
why would a why would a Nazi or why
would a NASA
scientist put this Bible verse just it's
like just the reference Psalm
191 Psalm 191 let's look it
up there it is and the heavens de
declare wait that's the Heaven and the
heavens declare the glory of God and the
firmament showeth his handiwork this is
a a rocket
scientist put this on his tombstone he
knew he didn't want to go to the Grave
believing a lie and he started telling
his
spokesperson um what's her name uh Ro
Carol Rosen Carol Rosen yeah he started
telling her the truth he said look
they're trying to weaponized space I
don't know why he was saying weaponized
space but he was saying they're going to
create create deceptions to justify why
they have weapons in the heavens weapons
to fight Christ at a second coming
they're going to say it's terrorists
they're going to say it's asteroids and
ultimately the final card they're going
to say it's aliens and that's why they
need to weaponize the heavens and really
these Elites are preparing because they
know time is running out they know Jesus
coming soon and the Bible literally says
that three unclean spirits like frogs
are going to gather the the milit of the
world to battle against the coming of
God Almighty and they're preparing for
that and that's what's happening now and
this guy put on his Tombstone the
heavens declare the glory of God and the
firmament showeth his handiwork that
firmament above us proves that there's a
Creator this isn't some Cosmic accident
where nothing exploded and created this
perfect balls in space and just enough
oxygen and just enough this and water
that life just spawned on its own and
crawled out of a primordial soup and
turned into a monkey and evolved into a
man that eliminates the idea of God and
and you can't have that
idea and and you can't have the idea of
big bang and evolution knowing that
there's a firmament that there's lights
in the heavens and all these things so
when he says the firmament in that Bible
verse the firmament declares God's
handiwork it's proof that's why Satan
that's why these people that work for
Satan are trying to hide that firmament
and say no way we're exploring space
we're going millions of light years out
there it's all to hide God ultimately
they're going to Mars occupy Mars that's
right we can't go back to the Moon we
lost that technology but we got a remote
control car driving around on Mars up
yeah and that same guy we were just
talking about Von brn he wrote about
Elon before Elon was born oh wow in the
1950s he wrote about Elon he said the
person occupying Mars the person given
the authority up there the chief officer
is going to be given the title Elon on
Mars El the Rockets he drew looked just
like Elon Elon a star was born that's
right old Elon yeah the good guy now
fighting for our freedom with his
soldier of Satan
costume it's all about Free Speech guys
so yeah they're ramping it up he's going
to be a hero I believe he's going to be
a new um Tony Stark character he already
is I mean he saved some of the flood
victims with starlink he's he's be Tony
Stark 2.0 and just wait it'll happen
pretty sure man well man we've been
going for two and a half hours it was
amazing thank you so much for sharing
what you got it doesn't look like
there's many questions but if you got
questions leave them in the comments
below we look at all these comments we
respond to 90 98% of them I'd like to
say and uh me or Joshua look at those
comments we take this stuff seriously we
believe that the truth will set you free
We Believe God's word is true
we're not going to
believe science falsely soall we want to
believe what God's word says we don't
want to be deceived we've been deceived
by everything movies Evolution
everything why are we going to not
question the things that we've been
taught that's what we talk about on CID
truth it's cool to use your brain if you
want to buy a t-shirt that says be cool
use your brain we got a store if you go
to candid truth.org if you want to
support this ministry you can do so by
going to canat truth.org and you can
click the Donate button you can do so by
going to cash app or vinmo and zel those
are on the screen and definitely go to
founded Earth Brothers uh YouTube
channel click subscribe you guys got
over 100,000 subscribers and a lot of
videos a lot of informative videos if
you didn't get your answer on this video
which is impossible to answer everything
go over there and binge watch that's
something I do recommend binge watching
so go and check that out watch and learn
along with us we're here learning
together staying hum sometimes we make
mistakes we're not perfect amen yeah
Mike is one of those yeah like he's
saying support him support humble truth
Seekers who are sharing things putting
themselves out there their reputation he
didn't have to talk about this because
we know it's not a popular topic you
want to get banned on the internet you
wanna you wanna they're like oh you're
doing this for money no we're gonna pick
a censored topic that's a great strategy
I can't even be monetized we got
rejected for monetization from YouTube
so just to let you guys know
yeah if you ever see a commercial at the
beginning or something it's probably
because of a copyright thing we we got
refused for copyright or we got refused
for monetization for talking about
controversial hurtful content yeah they
didn't send me the plaque when I got
100,000 they said no no no wow not you
buddy you don't represent
our yes I was so excited even though I
know their Illuminati triangle I didn't
really it was just like I see all these
other people getting them and it's a big
number it's a big deal you know just to
say like yeah look here it is guys show
my kids one day no it's like you don't
get one some of your content was deemed
not suitable for advertisers not for
viewers and it was my Bible this about
money it videos where I mentioned a
certain name you're not allowed to say
the messiah's name you know you can't
say that out loud wow not suitable for
advertisers it's harmful content guys
you gota be careful yeah at today's age
but yeah thanks a lot yeah and guys
please support Mikey supporting
Ministries is a Ministry you keeping
Ministries going is a Ministry I feel
that way now cuz you're fellow helpers
like it talks about in the Bible and I'm
starting to understand that we're all
one big family working together so thank
you for all you fellow helpers people in
the chat even if you were you know
moderators all those kind of cool people
seeing those familiar people the Tyler
porters of this world the awesomeness
Tracy Jones of this world all of you out
there some good people in the chat man
you got some good ones awesome yeah man
we love you guys we're so thankful that
you were here you stuck it through for
two and a half hours and hope you guys
learned something I did I I came to this
thinking oh you're going to show me all
the stuff I already know but I learned a
lot already so thanks man this is this
is a a topic that just continues we we
continue to get more wisdom on it the
more we research so every day awesome
we'll see you guys next time we'll be
back there should be a next time amen
thank youut us down even if they do if
you guys like this video please give it
a thumbs up it really helps get this
video out into the algorithm if you guys
are new here and you're not a sub
subscriber click that subscribe button
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss a single video we try to put out as
many videos as we can we do a lot of
lives we like to interact with you guys
and we're trying to build a community a
community of likeminded people so we
love you we thank you and we'll see you
next time on candid truth